ich rufe auf
den Einzelplan 11
Bundesministerium für Arbeit und
Soziales mit den Beschlussempfehlungen
des Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksachen
3.511 und 3.526
Berichterstattung haben die Abgeordneten
Katrin Michel dr Silke launert Markus
Kurt Claudia Raffelhüschen Ulrike
Schilke Ziesing und dr Gesine Lötzsch
hierzu liegt ein Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu vor für die
Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 90
Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst
hat das Wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion DR
Silke launert
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren in wenigen Tagen
beginnt die Adventszeit eine Zeit der
Besinnung und der Vorfreude ja gespannt
öffnen die Kinder jeden Tag ein Türchen
des Adventskalenders und des Gipfel dann
im Weihnachtsfest heutzutage ein Fest
der Geschenke auch in diesem Jahr ist
aber vieles anders denn für die meisten
ja wird es wohl deutlich weniger und dem
unter dem Weihnachtsbaum geben die
explodieren Gas und Lebensmittelpreise
betreffen jeden in allen Bereichen jeden
einzelnen Haushalt jede Familie und das
jetzt nicht nur bei den Geschenken
sondern bei den ganz
existenziellen Sachen Strom Gas bezahlen
denn nie bezahlen von Lebensmitteln es
geht schlicht und darum dabei
bei vielen Menschen darum ob sie frieren
und ob sie sich noch gesundes Essen
leisten können
schaut man sich allerdings den
Haushaltsplan unserer Bundesregierung an
da könnte man durchaus meinen alles ist
wie immer nein sogar besser der
Gabentisch ist reich gefüllt und die
Wünsche der Koalitionäre finden da auch
ihren Platz und dabei so könnte man
meinen seine frohe Botschaft der Ampel
dem weihnachtlichen Koalition Frieden
steht nichts entgegen wie gesagt Wünsche
erfüllt bis hin zu den Milliarden für
das Schiff Rettungsschiff von dem
Partner von Frau Trinkgeld dabei ist die
ehrliche Lage doch eine andere wir haben
es geschafft von der unsere diesen
Finanzminister in dem Jahr verteilt
natürlich auch mehrere Haushalte clever
gemacht fast 550
Milliarden neue Schulden anzuvisieren in
diesem Etat für nächstes Jahr 45,6
Milliarden neue Verschuldung bis ans
Grenze Ausreißen der Schulden Obergrenze
in einer Situation wo jeder andere
Bürger jeder Haushalt jedes Unternehmen
gucken muss sparen muss umschichten muss
Prioritäten setzen muss es ist nicht so
dass wir dieses Hilfspaket auch mit 200
Milliarden in der Sache zum Überbrücken
nicht teilen wir haben schon frühzeitig
auch Anträge im Plenum ich glaube im
März und im Juni war es schon gestellt
für diese Gas und strompreisbremse da
haben sie noch monatelang nichts getan
aber es ist doch klar es ist eine
Überbrückung wir können nicht auf Dauer
nur ganz große Milliardenbeträge in den
Raum stellen und glauben dass das
Problem löst es ist also wichtig
Schwerpunkte zu setzen statt Gießkanne
verantwortlich langfristiges Planen
statt Koalitionsfrieden sparen statt
Angst vor Auseinandersetzung und
entscheidend ist und bleibt man kann es
nicht oft genug sagen nicht nur
symptombehandlungssachen
Ursachenbekämpfung Energieangebot
erhöhen erhöhen erhöhen Ideologie hätten
wir haben keine Wahl
von einem ernsthaften bemühen
Prioritäten zu setzen kann ich jetzt
hier bei dem Methan nicht ausgehen auch
den gesamt Etat nicht im Gegenteil
insgesamt schafft es die Ampel wirklich
in dem ersten jahrzehntausend
zusätzliche Stellen und ganz ehrlich
dieses Angebot jetzt 1,5 1,6% Stellen zu
streichen gleichen diese 10.000 zum Teil
teure Stellen nicht ansatzweise aus in
dieser Zeit wo jeder sparen muss 10.000
zusätzliche Stellen in dieser Situation
des Bürgergeld hier mehrheitlich
beschlossen wir suchen alle Hände Ringen
Leute egal wo Gastro Handwerk verkauft
Pflege also man müsste Anreise setzen
mehr Arbeit lohnt sich mehr Menschen in
Arbeit dass er das Richtige und das
machen wir das Bürgergeld das Gegenteil
würde hier mehrheitlich beschlossen im
ersten halben Jahr fast keine Sanktionen
bei einer Familie bis 150.000 schon
Vermögen völlig falsches Signal zum
Glück zum Glück
sage ich mal haben die unionsregierten
Länder des im Bundesrat gestoppt sind ja
selbst die Grünen in den Regierungen in
dabei offensichtlich ist man da näher an
den Menschen und stellt sich die Frage
wie müssen das die Menschen empfinden
die nämlich das alles finanzieren und
die auch nicht viel mehr haben und die
sich abhakern und die auch Kinder
erziehen nebenher und die auch oft am
Limit sind und die auch ihre Gesundheit
riskieren auch das ist zur Wahrung des
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Friedens
wichtig und an die haben sie nämlich
nicht gedacht und deshalb ist der
Kompromiss jetzt da zum Glück kommt
natürlich ein inflationsbedingter
Ausgleich für die Hartz IV Empfänger
völlig richtig aber auch klar ist
fördern und fördern und dabei muss es
bleiben und das schlimmste wurde zum
Glück verhindert
wie gesagt mehr Anreize müssen es geben
in die Arbeit zu gehen die Menschen zu
motivieren wir haben in der
Bereinigungssitzung zahlreiche Anträge
da eingebracht wie das geht zum Beispiel
durch attraktivere Arbeitsbedingungen
für ältere Beschäftigte um die Länge in
Betrieb zu halten Aufbau digitaler
Angebote um die Ausbildungsplätze gerade
für die junge Leute besser zu
koordinieren und natürlich auch ein
inklusives Digitalpaket für berufliche
Bildung auch Menschen mit Handicaps sind
wertvoll die können super Online Shops
auch machen und unseren Arbeitsmarkt
bereichern alles was geht wir haben
gesagt wir wollen wir wöchentliche
Höchstarbeitszeit den er da Bremsen wir
die Leute aus die mehr leisten wollen
darum geht es Signal wir können aus
dieser Krise raus wir können unseren
Wohlstand auch erhalten aber jeden muss
klar sein nur wenn wir anpacken die Arme
hochkrempeln bereits in mehr zu arbeiten
und nicht den Leuten zu suggerieren ja
ja wir bezahlen euch schon eure Nachteil
diese Rechnung wird nicht aufgeben
viele Menschen in diesem Land werden
Ihren lieben dieses Jahr zu Weihnachten
weniger schenken können bitte liebe
Vertreter der Ampelkoalition treffen
auch sie zumindest im nächsten Haushalt
für diesen ist schon zu spät die
richtige Wahl beim Bestücken des
gabentisches nicht nur Symptombehandlung
Ursachenbekämpfung Angebot erhöhen
ideologieoffen ist hilft nichts anderes
und von diesen Geschenk haben die
Menschen wirklich länger etwas
nächste Rednerin für die SPD-Fraktion
Katrin Michel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister Hubertus Heil
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
chestioniklinie
wir befinden uns in herausfordernden
Zeiten komplexe Krisen die sich global
überlappen stellen und sie Gesellschaft
vor immense Herausforderungen und umso
mehr ist dieser Haushalt ein echter
Erfolg
mein Dank ist allen Beteiligten
Mitarbeitenden und ganz besonders der
Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
Kerstin Krise sie hatten den letzten
Wochen quasi 24/7 für uns Bericht
erstatten immer
für uns gestanden sie war jederzeit
ansprechbar und das wollte ich heute
nicht unerwähnt lassen
dem heute vorgelegten Haushalt 2023 ging
sehr intensive Verhandlungen voraus eins
war uns Haushälterin wichtig nämlich
darzustellen wie wichtig und wie
kraftvoll das parlamentarische Verfahren
ist und was wir Abgeordnete letztendlich
bewirken können und es gibt sie wirklich
die Abgeordneten die mit Herzblut die
mit Sachverstand und viel Verantwortung
bis an das andere ihrer Kräfte oft
streiten und verhandeln
und es gibt die anderen
mit großen Verantwortungsbewusstsein
haben wir einen Haushalt aufgestellt der
sich wirklich sehen lassen kann der
Einzelplan elf quasi das Mutterschiff
des Haushalts bildet auch 2023 mit
166,2 Milliarden Euro den größten
einzeletat und macht etwa ein Drittel
des Gesamthaushalts aus es ist uns
gelungen den Regierungsentwurf im
parlamentarischen Verfahren durch
Anpassen von Pflichtleistungen aufgrund
der Wirtschaftsprognosen noch einmal um
2,9 Milliarden Euro zu erhöhen so sorgen
wir auch im kommenden Jahr für ein gut
ausgestatteten und starken Sozialstaat
auf dem sich die Menschen verlassen
können
Zusammenhalt in der zweiten Wende
bedeutet dass wir gerade in Krisenzeiten
in den Sozialstaat investieren und
wohlüberlegte Ausgaben für die soziale
Sicherung und ein stabilen Arbeitsmarkt
tätigen
gegenüber dem Regierungsentwurf zum
Haushalt 2023 stellen wir den Jobcentern
zusätzlich 500 Millionen Euro für
Eingliederungsleistungen und die
Verwaltung zur Verfügung das ist ein
bedeutendes Plus von dem viele Menschen
in unserem Land profitieren werden
weiterhin ist es uns gelungen die
Regelung zur Inanspruchnahme von
ausgaberesten beim Eingliederungstitel
in Höhe von bis zu 600 Millionen Euro zu
verstehen mit den insgesamt 10,3
Milliarden Euro sind die Jobcenter fürs
kommende Jahr gut aufgestellt das gibt
Perspektive das gibt Planungssicherheit
in unsicheren Zeiten und es ist ein
wesentlicher Beitrag zur Umsetzung des
Bürgergeldes
mit den zwei 10,3 Milliarden Euro
ermöglichen wird genau dem
Paradigmenwechsel für den wir als SPD
schon so lange gekämpft haben diejenigen
in unserer Gesellschaft die aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen nicht in der
Lage sind eigenständig auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt Fuß zu fassen werden durch
Support der Jobcenter dabei unterstützt
ein Berufsabschluss zu machen und
bekommen so die Chance langfristig und
nachhaltig auf dem Arbeitsmarkt bestehen
zu können
und das liebe Union ist das wirkliche
Herzstück der bürgergeldreform und dafür
sind die 10,3 Milliarden gut investiert
und helfen unser Volkswirtschaft dabei
dem Fachkräftemangel entgegenzuwirken
wir müssen den veränderten
Rahmenbedingungen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
Rechnung tragen alles andere wäre
kurzsichtig und schlicht
unverantwortlich
unverantwortlich ist leider auch das
Bild dass sie liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus den Reihen der Union in den
vergangenen Wochen mit Blick auf die
Menschen bemühen die Leistungen aus dem
SGB II beziehen
ob es der von Ihnen gesetzte Fokus auf
Sanktionsmechanismen ist
rund 97 Prozent der
Leistungsberechtigten bleiben davon
unberührt dass das wissen wir alle
schlimme aber noch finde ich diese
unsägliche neiggebacke mit Debatte die
auch vorhin Kollegin launert noch mal
bedient hat eine Neiddebatte in der sie
geringverdienende gegen Arbeitslose
ausspielen das ist schäbig und das passt
in meinen Augen so gar nicht in ein Bild
einer christlichen Partei
wir gehen mit den Bürgergeld den
zugewandten Weg wir schenken Vertrauen
und sorgen zugleich dafür dass
Anstrengung belohnt wird der
Kompromissvorschlag aus dem
Vermittlungsausschuss der Morgen zur
Abstimmung steht behält den Kern unserer
Bürger Geldreform ein echten
Kulturwandel in der Arbeitsmarktpolitik
bei er ist ein Erfolg für uns ab
1.1.2023 kommt das neue Bürgergeld
mit dem heute die krankenhaushalt setzen
wir weitere wichtige Vorhaben aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag um wir starten das
Bundesprogramm Barrierefreiheit um
unsere Vorhaben für mehr Inklusion und
Teilhabe im Alltag voranzutreiben wir
bauen die erfolgreiche Beratungsarbeit
der bundesfachstelle Barrierefreiheit
und der Überwachungsstelle barrierefreie
it aus und stellen den
partizipationsfonds zur Förderung von
selbstvertretungsorganisationen von
Menschen mit Behinderung rund 40 Prozent
mehr Mittel zur Verfügung
und wir haben die Errichtung einer
Stiftung zur Umsetzung des
härtefallfonds auf den Weg gebracht
endlich buchstäblich in letzter Sekunde
und gerade noch rechtzeitig und nun
können wir den betroffenen Menschen
denen unter anderem vor Hintergrund der
rentenüberleitung erhebliche Nachteile
entstanden sind und die gleichzeitig
eine sehr niedrige Rente beziehen eine
finanzielle Kompensation zukommen zu
lassen ich appelliere an dieser Stelle
erneut und nachdrücklich an die Länder
und ganz besonders auch an meinen
Bundesland in Sachsen folgen Sie dem
guten Beispiel des Bundes folgen Sie dem
Bundesland Mecklenburg-Vorpommern treten
sie der Stiftung bei und verdoppeln Sie
den Beitrag des Bundes für die in ihrem
Land lebenden Betroffenen zeigen sie
endlich Respekt
herzlichen Dank und Glück auf
Kathrin Michel war das die
Berichterstatterin der SPD es geht um
den Einzelplan 11 Arbeit und Soziales
der größte Einzelposten mit
166,23 Milliarden Euro mehr als ein
Drittel des Gesamtetats von Christian
Lindner so Ulrike Schielke sie sind
jetzt für die AFD
es ist gerade einmal zwei Wochen her da
standen wir hier und debattierten über
das sogenannte Bürgergeld ich war gerade
zu entsetzt über diesen Tiefpunkt der
Debattenkultur solche Beschimpfungen mit
denen sie die Einwände der Opposition
abgebügelt haben die gehören nicht hier
hin
aber diese dünhaltigkeit zeigte auch mit
der massiven Kritik die ja nicht nur von
den Verbänden und den Bundesrechnungshof
kam nein auch von der Basis ihrer
Parteien damit haben sie nicht gerechnet
nur so ist die Erleichterung zu erklären
mit der sie sich sozusagen
gezwungenermaßen von einigen der
gröbsten Schnitzer verabschieden dürfen
doch das was übrig bleibt ist leider
kaum besser es bleibt dabei das
Bürgergeld ist kontraproduktiv es lädt
zu Missbrauch ein und ist ein Schlag ins
Gesicht derjenigen die jeden Morgen
aufstehen um sich ja Einkommen selbst zu
erarbeiten
noch schlimmer es erhöht die Gefahr
drastisch dass Menschen in die
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit landen und dort
bleiben wer das bestreitet hat lange
nicht mehr Mitarbeiter in der Jobcenter
gesprochen und das in einer Zeit in der
es kaum etwas Wichtigeres gibt als so
viele Menschen wie möglich in Arbeit zu
bringen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute
sprechen wir aber darüber was das alles
kostet und wie das finanziert werden
soll und siehe da wurden Gesetzesentwurf
noch 4,8 Milliarden Euro veranschlagt
werden finden sich im Einzelplan 11 nur
noch rund 3 schon die Heizkosten müssen
sie auch aus den 60er finanzieren und
das im ersten Jahr der Einführung was
kommt danach schaffen sie das Bürgergeld
dann wieder ab wenn die Einnahmen
wegbrechen so wie das ja jetzt absehbar
ist wir stehen ja bekanntlich am Anfang
einer schweren Rezession und einer Welle
von Firmeninsolvenzen viele Menschen
werden ihre Arbeit verlieren die
Inflation steigt weiter und damit auch
die Kosten für die Lebenshaltung wer das
nicht mehr stemmen kann landet bald im
Sozialsystem und das alles muss in
Zukunft auch bezahlt werden und ich
frage mich allmählich wovon
die Ampel regiert nach dem Motto pi mal
Daumen nach Kassenlage und hofft mit
geschlossenen Augen auf das beste all
das erinnert an die Grundrente dort
wurden ja eigentlich auch ein richtiges
Anliegen nämlich die Erhöhung der Mittel
für sozialbedürftige ideologisch
überfrachtet und entgegen aller Vernunft
ins Gegenteil verkehrt auch die
Grundrente war ein Prestige-Objekt von
Herrn Haie aber um Herrn Harbeck zu
zitieren es ist ja nur Geld eine
geradezu metaphysischer Einstellung die
erklärt mit welcher Großzügigkeit mit
dem Geld der Steuerzahler umgegangen
wird die Ampel hat sich bereits im
ersten Jahr ihrer Regierung mit rund 550
Milliarden verschuldet nicht genug im
Schatten daneben türmen sich und für 28
kreativ betitelte Sondervermögen für
dies und das in Milliarden Höhe Schulden
die nicht im Bundeshaushalt auftauchen
die Arbeit zurückgezahlt werden müssen
von unseren Kindern und Enkeln und seit
neuestem auch für die aktienrente
grundsätzlich ist es richtig über eine
langfristige Ergänzung der
fragefinanzierung in der
Rentenversicherung nachzudenken aber so
zu tun als ob man mit einem Anschub von
10 Milliarden Euro die
Rentenversicherung Demografie festmachen
könnte ist lächerlich zum Vergleich das
Volumen der gesetzlichen
Rentenversicherung beträgt schon heute
rund 330 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr ein
Drittel davon sind Steuerzuschüsse daran
gemessen ist die Summe um die es hier
geht nicht mal ein Tropfen auf den
heißen Stein
für einen nennenswerten Effekt müsste
man also einen weit höheren Betrag und
zwar jährlich als feste Ausgabe
einplanen wenn man das Geld dann hätte
stattdessen muss sogar der Einzug von 10
Milliarden Euro auf kreditfinanziert
werden Herr Lindner zockt also mit der
Erwartung dass die Erträge dieser
Kapitalanlagen langfristig die Kosten
übersteigen die er wegen steigender
Zinsen dafür zahlen muss das ist
gefährlich die Alternative ist dagegen
unbequem Umsteuern und sparen was das
Zeug hält sämtliche Ausgaben müssen auf
den Prüfstand unter der Vorgabe was ist
wirklich notwendig und sinnvoll was
brauchen wir um die wirtschaftlichen
Grundlagen des Landes zu sichern und
wovon müssen wir uns verabschieden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nichts davon
ist zu erkennen nichts davon ist gewollt
und das ist beängstigend denn es schadet
unserem Land dauerhaft
denn so werden weiterhin Milliarden für
ideologischen Unsinn versenkt während am
anderen Ende das Geld fehlt zum Beispiel
für die angemessene Ausstattung das
härtefallfonds das betrifft
hunderttausende ost-rentner die vielfach
in Armut leben weil ihnen bekanntlich
durch Verfahrensfehler bei der
Überleitung ins westdeutsche Rentenrecht
ein Teil ihrer Rente genommen wurde die
angedachte Lösung bleibt finanziell weit
hinter den berechtigten Erwartungen
zurück sogar ihr SPD-Kollege dulig
bezeichnete sie als Zitat politischen
Kompromiss auf kleinstem gemeinsamen
Nenner das ist zu wenig das hilft nicht
und das ist den Menschen die so lange
auf Unterstützung warten nicht
angemessen deshalb appelliere ich an sie
vergrößern Sie diesen gemeinsamen Nenner
tun Sie was richtig ist für andere Dinge
ist ja anscheinend auch Geld da vielen
Dank
der nächste Redner in der Debatte über
den Etat des bundesarbeitsministers
Hubertus Heil kommt von den
Bündnisgrünen Markus Kurt er ist der
Berichterstatter für seine Fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Kolleginnen dr launert meine Kollegen
von der cdu/csu-fraktion gerne hätte ich
jetzt hier von dieser Stelle aus über
die Höhe des eingliederungstitels zur
Förderung von Langzeitarbeitslosen
diskutiert ob der ausreicht oder nicht
wir haben ja immerhin 500 Millionen
wieder reingeholt gerne hätte ich über
Zahlen diskutiert auch zur
berufsbezogenen Sprachförderung und
dergleichen aber was muss ich mir hier
stattdessen anhören wieder werden
Langzeitarbeitslose oder Menschen die
etwa weil sie alleinerziehend sind und
deswegen ihrem Arbeitslosengeld zwei
landen diffamiert und als
Projektionsfläche missbraucht für Risse
und die Mond Neid und Missgunst
wieder muss ich mir hier anhören wie sie
Mindestlohn beziehende
instrumentalisieren denn nichts anderes
tun sie um ein Differenzen herzustellen
und sie werden auch den arbeitenden in
diesem Bereich überhaupt nicht gerecht
damit denn Arbeit ist mehr als Geld
Arbeit ist Teilhabe und bedeutet
Austausch und soziale und auch
gesundheitliche Stabilität wenn es nur
um das Kalkül ginge wenn es nur um das
Finanzielle Kalkül gegen dürfte es ja
gar keine arbeitenden Menschen geben die
auf einen Anspruch auf ergänzendes
Arbeitslosengeld 2 verzichten die
sogenannte verdeckte Armut das zeigt
doch wie viele Menschen stolz sind dass
sie ihre Arbeit haben die gar nicht
angewiesen sein wollen auf das Jobcenter
und auf Kosten dieser Menschen Politik
zu machen ist unerhört
und wenn sie und wenn sie den
Mindestlohn beziehen dann wirklich
gerecht werden wollen und den
geringverdienenden dann tun Sie etwas
zur Stärkung etwa von Tarifbindung und
tarifreue das wäre dann der ehrliche
Ansatz an der Stelle
und stattdessen arbeiten sie mit
falschen Zahlen was sie auch am Ende
zugegeben haben und der Kollege Jens
Spahn wird von der taz am 20.11
interviewt und ihm wird das vorgehalten
mit den falschen Zahlen Antwort Jens
Spahn standen in der Tatzen noch die
falsche Zahlen das spricht doch wohl für
sich diese Antwort standen da noch nie
falsche Zahlen aber die Interviewerin
gibt Jens Spahn noch eine zweite Chance
stellt die Frage wäre da nicht eine
Entschuldigung angesagt Antwort Jens
Spahn es geht um die Frage ob sich
arbeiten lohnt oder nicht diese Debatten
müssen wir führen das finde ich wirklich
unerhört sie hätten da klatschen sie
auch noch da klatschen sie auch noch es
ist ja noch nicht mal der Versuch von
Jens Spahn an dieser Stelle zu verhehlen
das falsche Zahlen zu Kampagnenführung
verwendet worden sind
und wenn
und wenn man daneben noch die Äußerungen
legt des bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten
der dann gesagt hat wie diogen ist faul
in der Tonne liegt der kriegt keine
Leistung und das Ganze vor dem Grillen
im bierzeltpublikum von sich gegeben hat
wenn man das zusammenlegt dann sieht man
dass dieser Ansatz Spaltung als
politisches Geschäftsmodell ist
und welche Geister wecken Sie welche
Geister sie wecken das konnten sie
gerade hier in der Rede von Frau
Schielke sie singen hören und in vielen
anderen Sachen auch nachlesen und hören
und ich sage Ihnen bevor sie sich so
aufregen aus der Union ich will diese
Spaltung nicht ich möchte das bewusst
nicht nein deswegen werde ich sie auch
nicht pauschal verteufeln oder gar in
die Nähe der AFD Stellen ich weiß
nämlich dass es bei ihnen Menschen gibt
die das besser wissen Hermann Gröhe will
ich nennen Karl Josef Laumann
stellvertretend von einem halben Jahr
war ich beim Jobcenter Münster kommunal
ist Jobcenter der jobcenterleiter
CDU-Mitglied ist mit mir und der
Sozialdezernentin dort den
Koalitionsvertrag durchgegangen und fand
das nicht alles aber überwiegend
vernünftig vor allen Dingen fand er den
Ansatz vernünftig eine Vertrauensbasis
ist aufzubauen um dann Motivation und
Befähigung zu schaffen diesen
Grundeinsatz fand er völlig richtig und
er sagt mir sinn das machen wir hier in
Münster schon sowieso und das
das sind Personen
aus der Union die mir die Hoffnung geben
dass wir zum rationalen und vernünftigen
Diskurs an der Stelle führen kommen und
es gibt doch Hoffnung und das ist eben
der Ansatz den wir dann auch versuchen
im Haushalt wiederum abzubilden die
Haltung die sich im morgen zu
verabschiedenen bürgergeldgesetz
wiederfindet aber eben auch die
finanzielle Hinterlegung die wir machen
und wir sehen auch die Vielfalt der
verschiedenen Problemlagen die im
Sozialgesetzbuch zwei oder im
Bürgerrecht sind es handelt sich ja
keineswegs überwiegend um
Langzeitarbeitslose sondern um Kinder
und Jugendlichen zu einem sehr großen
Teil Alleinerziehende es geht um
Menschen die vielleicht aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen
Beeinträchtigungen haben es geht um
Aufstocker es geht um eine ganze
Vielfalt des Lebens und diese Vielfalt
des Lebens die muss man im Umgang mit
Personen die auf Unterstützung
angewiesen sind abbilden die Zahlen sind
das eine das dürre was sozusagen
auf dem Papier steht und das andere ist
die Haltung mit mehr mit der man diese
Zahlen mit Leben erfüllt
und das ist am Ende auch
Wirtschaftspolitik wir haben nämlich
eine ganz andere Situation als zu der
Zeit als das SGB II ich war selbst dabei
ins Leben gerufen wurde wir haben jetzt
keine Massenarbeitslosigkeit sondern wir
haben einen Arbeitskräftemangel nicht
nur
facharbeitskräftemangel sondern
Arbeitskräftemangel und es geht darum
die Potenziale nicht nur aus
menschlichen Gründen sondern auch aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen die Potenziale
zu heben diese großartigen Potenziale
die wir in diesem Land mit allen
Menschen haben ist das niemand verloren
gehen und das ist unser Ansatz vielen
Dank
und in dieser ersten Runde zum einzelnen
elfarbeit und Soziales hat jetzt für die
Linke die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
gesehene Lötsch das Wort ist die
Berichterstatterin und sie gehört auch
zum Vermittlungsausschuss der gestern
Abend das Bürgergeld durchgehen hat
und Grüne unter aktiver Mitwirkung von
Union und FDP die harzgesetze eingeführt
wir haben damals gesagt Hartz IV ist
Armut per Gesetz das hat sich leider
bewahrheitet und darum brauchen wir
einen grundlegenden Systemwechsel meine
Damen und Herren
ich verstehe dass die hartz-iv-parteien
ihr Hartz IV mit Schluss werden wollen
das Bürgergeld enthält einige
Verbesserungen und darum haben wir im
Bundestag das Gesetz auch nicht
abgelehnt doch das Vermittlungsverfahren
hat das Gesetz nicht besser sondern
schlechter gemacht und das ist schade
meine Damen und Herren der damalige
Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder SPD sagte
stolz wir haben den größten
Niedriglohnsektor Europas geschaffen ich
finde das eine fatale Aussage eine
Million Menschen die einer regelmäßigen
Arbeit nachgehen müssen aufstocken
welche Demütigung so darf das nicht
weitergehen
was wir brauchen sind deutlich höhere
Löhne und eine effektive Kontrolle der
Einhaltung des Mindestlohnes alles
andere ist lohndruckerei meine Damen und
Herren von Union und FDP merken Sie sich
das
die Erhöhung der Regelsätze ist
überfällig bei Preissteigerung von
Grundnahrungsmitteln von 20% in einem
Jahr sind 53 Euro mehr Hartz 4 im Monat
eben kein ausreichender
Inflationsausgleich der Paritätische
Wohlfahrtsverband hat neu berechnet und
fordert ein Regelsatz von 725 € pro
Monat über diese Forderung sollten wir
alle gemeinsam nachdenken meine Damen
und Herren und sie unterstützen
bei den Sanktionen hat die Ampel schnell
eine Rolle rückwärts gemacht die
Regierung mag offensichtlich Sanktionen
allerdings nicht bei allen wenn es
nämlich um Einkommensmillionäre geht die
bei der steuerbetrügen da sind sie sehr
großzügig der Bundesrechnungshof hat
bereits im Jahr 2006 bemängelt das
Einkommensmillionäre zu selten geprüft
werden die Prüfquote ist in den
vergangenen Jahren nicht gestiegen
sondern gesunken und das ist fatal meine
Damen und Herren der Chef ist die Idee
rechnet uns vor dass der Schaden durch
Steuerhinterziehung pro Jahr 100
Milliarden Euro beträgt der Schaden
durch Hartz IV betrug macht 60 Millionen
Euro aus mit diesem Missverhältnis haben
die Hartz iv-parteien offensichtlich
kein Problem meine Damen und Herren es
ist beängstigend wie die schmächtige FDP
knallhart die Interessen der Vermögen in
dieser Koalition durchsetzt gehen sie
aufeinander Weg meine Damen und Herren
von SPD grün ansonsten landen sie in der
Ecke der FDP das kann doch nicht ihr
Ziel sein herzlichen Dank
Gesine lütsch von der Linksfraktion war
das und weiter geht's mit der FDP
Claudia Raffel und auch sie ist die
Berichterstatterin für den Bereich
Arbeit und Soziales für ihre Fraktion
jetzt wird es wieder ein bisschen
ruhiger
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin lieber
Minister Hubertus Heil liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die Aufstellung des
Arbeits- und
Sozialetats Entschuldigung in diesem
Jahr war besonders anspruchsvoll Corona
Ukraine Krieg und Energiekrise all das
tangiert insbesondere den Einzelplan 11
wir haben einen soliden
Regierungsentwurf in den letzten Wochen
noch weiter konsolidieren können denn
die Frage wie wir das zur Verfügung
stehende Geld noch besser verausgaben
können bleibt ein wichtiger Grundsatz
und zwar immer nicht nur in Krisenzeiten
absolut klar war für uns deshalb dass
alle Änderungen die wir als Koalition im
Regierungsentwurf vornehmen im eigenen
Etage gegen finanziert sind so gewähren
wir jetzt der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
und den Jobcentern mehr Spielraum im
Bereich der Eingliederung und
kompensieren hier einmalig im
Haushaltsjahr 2023 und aufgrund des
entstehende Mehrbedarfs durch den rechts
Wechsel der Ukraine geflüchteten über
das Bürgergeld das ist sachlogisch denn
wir setzen hiermit einen Anreiz zu mehr
aktiv statt passivleistung
selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich bleibt es bei unserem
Grundsatz arbeit muss sich lohne deshalb
gilt es diejenigen zu unterstützen die
aus dem Ausland in unseren Arbeitsmarkt
hinzukommen sich fort und weiterbilden
wollen oder keine Chance auf berufliche
Qualifikation bisher hatten im
Gesamtbudget SGB II stehen den
Jobcentern unter Einbezug aller
Ausgabeposten nun
10,35 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung hier
haben wir also deutlich verstärkt und
den Hilferufen aus den Jobcentern
[Applaus]
mehr Menschen in Arbeit zu bringen muss
unser Hauptziel sein und bleiben denn
wir entlasten damit darüber hinaus auch
unsere Sozialversicherungssysteme
außerdem starten wir das Bundesprogramm
Barrierefreiheit mit zwei Millionen Euro
Anstoß Finanzierung für mehr Teilhabe
für mehr Teilhabe beeinträchtigt der
Menschen am gesellschaftlichen Leben
pünktlich zum Internationalen Tag der
Menschen mit Behinderung am dritten
Dezember setzen wir ein Zeichen und
ermöglichen dass die mit dem Programm
verbundene Maßnahmen in 2023 pünktlich
starten können
da wir Haushaltspolitiker unsere Arbeit
als Hüter des Gesetzes als Hüter des
Geldes
freut ernst nehmen haben wir die
Ausgaben gesperrt bis uns ein Konzept
über die konkrete Ausgestaltung der
Bundesinitiative vorgelegt wird wir
wollen zu sicherstellen dass das
zusätzliche Geld auch wirklich Sache
erreicht verausgabt wird darüber hinaus
stärken wir die nationale
Armutskonferenz den sogenannten
partizipationsform in den bisherigen
Förderentscheidungen
in den bisherigen Förderentscheidung
konnten aufgrund der knappen
Mittelausstattung nicht alle Anträge
bewilligt werden etwa aus dem Bereich
der Gehörlosen Community mit den
zusätzlichen Mitteln sollen nunmehr
Spielraum geschaffen werden um weitere
Projekte fördern zu können
mit all diesen Vorhaben setzen wir
weitere zentrale Versprechen aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag um und zeigen
gleichwohl das Steuergeld ein endliches
gut ist denn wir finanzieren diese aus
dem eigenen
oftmals hat der Staat leider nicht nur
ein Ausgabenproblem sondern auch ein
ausgabenstrukturproblem nicht nur über
das Wie viel sondern auch das wofür
haben wir uns gemeinsam mit dem BMAS
ausgetauscht ich bin sehr froh darüber
dass wir im Kapitel Arbeitswelt im
Wandel hier liegt der Mittelabfluss seit
Jahren deutlich unter dem veranschlagten
zollansatz 10 Millionen Euro zugunsten
des Bundeshaushalts kürzen konnten
Koalition und BMS setzen damit ein
gemeinsames Zeichen wo Geld nicht
gebraucht wird setzen wir es frei
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
natürlich bleibt ein zentraler
krisenherz des Einzelplans die Rente
denn die Zukunftsfähigkeit unserer
Rentenversicherung hat höchste Priorität
ich freue mich deshalb wirklich über den
Einstieg in ein Kapital gedecktes System
mit dem mit dem Renteneintritt der
Babyboomer ab dem Jahr 2025 werden
unsere Rentenkassen jedoch unter noch
massiveren Drucker an sie haben weniger
Kinder geboren sind jedoch selbst viele
die Rentenversicherung sieht sich also
bald mit immer weniger Einzahlern und
immer mehr Empfängern konfrontiert
dieser demografische Effekt wird noch
eklatanter wenn wir die steigende
Lebenserwartung hinzuziehen und die
Rente somit immer länger bezogen wird
die fünf großen rentenzuschüsse betragen
im Jahr
2023 zusammen
106,6 Milliarden Euro hier ist etwas aus
dem Fugen geraten und es braucht nun
dringend sanfte Impulse an den
Stellschrauben der Rente und mehr
Flexibilität beim Renten Eintrittsalter
denn selbstverständlich sollte ein
Dachdecker nicht mit 60 Jahren noch
weiter arbeiten andere Berufsgruppen
könnten und wollten das aber durchaus
leider hat es bisher fast fast keine
Regierung geschafft im Rentensystem eine
Therapie zu verabreichen wir machen das
anders und denken langfristig für unsere
Kinder und Enkelkinder
genau 10 Milliarden Euro Kapitalstock
sind ein Lichtblick ein guter Anfang und
ein sehr gutes Signal für unsere Jugend
eine Note Operation an unserem
eigentliche umlagefinanzierten System
ersetzen sie jedoch nicht lieber Herr
Minister ich würde mich über einen
gemeinsamen Aufbruch freuen lassen sie
uns hierbei oder hierzu zu dem Thema
immer im Gespräch bleiben
abschließend noch eine Erfolgsmeldung es
geht um den Fonds zur Abmilderung von
Härtefällen in der rentenüberleitung für
Spätaussiedler und jüdische Zuwanderer
der im Bundeshaushalt 2032 jetzt nicht
mehr etatisiert ist für das aktuelle
laufende Haushaltsjahr stehen 500
Millionen Euro zur Verfügung die mit
einer Sperre versehen war
ursprünglich sollte das formvolumen von
dem Bundesländern und den gleichen
Betrag ergänzt werden hier wurde eine
gemeinschaftliche Beteiligung seitens
der Länder aber abgelehnt
das ist aus mehreren Gründen wirklich
zynisch denn erstens wo dem Bundesrat
oft und vehement angemahnt dass mehr für
die beschriebenen Bedarfsgruppen getan
werden muss
zweitens sprechen wir hier bei Menschen
im fortgeschrittenem Alter die eine
Entschädigung nicht nur aus finanziellen
sondern eben auch aus symbolischen
Gründen mehr als verdient hätten und
drittens weisen die Länder gegenüber dem
Bund ein deutlichen Einnahme bzw
Haushaltsüberschuss auch als
Ampelkoalition haben wir die Sperre in
der vergangenen Sitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses aufgehoben so dass
der Bundesanteil nun bald an die
Anspruchsberechtigten ausgezahlt werden
kann
der Bund wird die möglichen Ausfall der
häftigen Beteiligung durch die
Bundesländer jedoch nicht kompensieren
und das ist richtig liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wie sagte schon
Hans-Dietrich Genscher liberale Wissen
verantwortliche Politik muss der
Freiheit und der würde jedes einzelne
Menschen dienen aber Freiheit und
Verantwortung gehören für uns lieberale
untrennbar zusammen daher gilt wir sind
für die Menschen in diesem Land da wir
lassen niemanden alleine gleichwohl gilt
aber auch wir haben eine große
Verantwortung für die zukünftigen
Generation sind unsere Kinder und unsere
Enkelkinder und ihnen wollen wir
hoffentlich alle ein solideren Staat
hinterlassen ich danke Ihnen
Claudia Raffelhüschen war das für die
FDP der nächste Rena kommt von der
cdu/csu Stefan Stracke er Sprecher für
Arbeit und Soziales der Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren der
Vermittlungsausschuss hat gestern den
Weg frei gemacht für die
Weiterentwicklung von Hartz IV und
voraussichtlich werden wir ja am Freitag
darüber auch hier im Deutschen Bundestag
beschließen wir werden als
Unionsfraktion diesen Gesetzesentwurf
zustimmen und entscheidend und wichtig
für uns insbesondere die Anpassung der
Regelsätze an die hohen Teuerungsraten
die schnelle Anpassung stammt dabei nie
im politischen Streit wir sorgen jetzt
für Sicherheit für diejenigen die darauf
angewiesen sind das ist notwendig und
richtig meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren dass wir das tun
das Arbeitslosengeld 2 landläufig ja
Hartz IV genannt sichert Menschen in
existenzieller not verlässlich ab und
entscheidend ist gerade in der jetzigen
Situation dass ich Arbeitslosigkeit
nicht verfestigt dass aus
Arbeitslosigkeit nicht
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit entsteht und
dass wir diejenige die auf Hilfe
angewiesen sind dazu befähigen
ertüchtigen und ermutigen doch auf diese
Hilfe zu verzichten dass sie wieder
selber möglichst schnell und dauerhaft
wieder ein Arbeit kommen und da waren
wir in den letzten 16 Jahren unsere
Regierungszeit sehr erfolgreich darin
über 2,2 Millionen Menschen haben wir
zurückgebracht in Arbeit haben es
geschafft dass sie ein festen Platz in
der Arbeitsgesellschaft haben das ein
großer Erfolg der natürlich mit Hartz IV
in diesem Bereich intensiv zusammenhält
ob die Voraussetzungen dass ein solcher
Erfolg auch jetzt wieder gelingen kann
sind so gut wie nie zuvor 1,9 Millionen
Stellen sind offen viele davon sind
fachkräftestellen aber natürlich auch
arbeitskräftestellen und wir müssen
jetzt alles dafür tun dass der Weg aus
der Arbeitslosigkeit zurück in Arbeit
gelingt denn klar ist Arbeit ist viel
mehr als bloßer Broterwerb er hat vor
allem mit
Anerkennung mit Selbstwertgefühl und mit
Teilhabe zu tun und deswegen war es uns
so wichtig dass das Grundprinzip fördern
und fordern auch weiterhin geht und zwar
vom ersten Tag an intensiv sich mit dem
einzelnen auseinanderzusetzen zu sehen
wo seine Problemlagen sind in so
motivieren und zu aktivieren und dazu
gehört eben auch dass man
Eigenbemühungen
Mitwirkungspflichten verbindlich
einfordern kann das ist auch ein Gebot
der Fairness gegenüber dem Steuerzahler
der mit seinen Steuermitteln dafür sorgt
dass dieses System auch finanziert ist
und funktioniert und deswegen
haben wir als Union dafür gesorgt dass
es zu keinem Systemwechsel kommt so wie
er im Gesetzesentwurf ja ursprünglich
auch beabsichtigt war ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen kommt
nicht und das ist auch die entscheidende
Veränderung die wir durchgesetzt haben
dass vom ersten Tag an nicht nur melde
Versäumnisse entsprechend geahndet
werden können sondern auch
Pflichtverletzung und deswegen
und deswegen gilt
die Schonzeit von einem halben Jahr es
vom Tisch der Freischuss bei
Pflichtverletzungen ist vom Tisch und
dies gilt alles dann auch zum ersten
Januar des nächsten Jahres wenn die
Zustimmung dann am Freitag erfolgen wird
von diesem Hohen Haus denn der
sanktionsmonatorium wird auch frühzeitig
beendet nämlich zum ersten Januar auch
das ist ein richtiger Erfolg denn das
Grundprinzip fördern und fördern muss
gelten von tag ein tag eins an
wir verändern auch noch mals die Regeln
was die Karenzzeit angeht ein Jahr statt
zwei Jahre der Schonvermögen wird
erheblich reduziert alles andere wäre
auch überhaupt nicht vermittelbar
gewesen gegen gegen dem gegenüber der
mit einem kleinen Einkommen
beispielsweise und mit seinen
Steuermitteln dafür sorgt dass derjenige
dann Leistungen bezieht obwohl er diese
in dieser Form auch gar nicht notwendig
hat das hat etwas mit Nachhaltigkeit und
dem Nachgang Grundsatz in diesem Bereich
zu tun
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkung aus der SPD-Fraktion ja er hat
sich gerne bitte schön
Herr Stracke es freut mich ja zu hören
dass ihre Fraktion dem Gesetz jetzt am
Ende voraussichtlich zustimmen wird
bezüglich des Kompromisses den sie
gerade referieren möchte ich doch
tatsächlich noch mal fragen und zwar
stellen sie ja da die Karenzzeit wird
jetzt verkürzt von zwei Jahren auf ein
Jahr das ist richtig das steht so in dem
Kompromiss sie sagen nun das sei aber
eben auch verhältnismäßig und richtig
okay ich möchte Sie fragen ist Ihnen
bekannt dass das vor allem für
diejenigen Menschen jetzt ein Problem
wird die z.B eine Qualifizierung
anstreben weil wenn man sich mal anguckt
jetzt nur 12 Monate zu haben bedeutet
eben wenn man eben den die Leistungen
beantragt dann den kooperationsplan
erarbeitet dann eine entsprechende
Qualifizierung vermittelt bekommt wenn
die in sechs Monate geht beispielsweise
man dann noch einen neuen Job finden
muss dass es genau die Leute sind die
trifft die dann neu aus der Karenzzeit
rausfallen werden und das ist eigentlich
ein gemeinsames Anliegen war die
Weiterbildung zu stärken erste Frage
zweite Frage ist ihn eigentlich bekannt
sie haben ja gerade über die
Pflichtverletzung gesprochen dass die
Regelung zu den Pflichtverletzungen
gegenüber dem ursprungsgesetz ja jetzt
sogar noch mal abgemildert wurden denn
neu ist ja jetzt dass bei der ersten
Pflichtverletzung nur einen Monat mit
10% sanktioniert wurden vorher waren es
drei Monate mit 20%, also von einer
Verschärfung der Sanktion kann doch
eigentlich gar keine Rede sein sind ihm
diese Umstände bekannt
die Frau Kollegin vielen herzlichen Dank
für ihre beiden Fragen die ich sehr
gerne natürlich auch beantworte zum
einen was das Thema der Karenzzeit
angeht also sie haben zunächst einmal
zwei Jahre Karenzzeit vorgesehen gehabt
und ich muss sagen es ist schon ein
Übermaß an dem was notwendig ist weil
sie das auch immer vermitteln müssen
gegenüber demjenigen der mit seinen
stollenmitteln dazu beiträgt dass diese
System auch funktioniert und bezahlt
wird und deswegen ist es nicht
nachvollziehbar gegenüber demjenigen der
mit seinen Erwerbseinkommen dazu
beiträgt und wenig Vermögen jetzt
endlich hat dass er diejenigen dann
unterstützen soll der beispielsweise
60.000 € auf der hohen Kante hat und
deswegen haben wir natürlich dafür
gesorgt dass dieses schon Vermögen
reduzierte das ist eine Frage der
Gerechtigkeit und der
Nachvollziehbarkeit auf das Systems das
sie diese Fehlstellung wir in diesem
Bereich tatsächlich beseitigt haben und
wir machen damit mit diesem einen Jahr
auch die den Kopf frei für diejenigen
die beispielsweise sagen sie wollen
jetzt in die Ausbildung oder
Qualifizierung hineingehen auch dafür
sorgen wir entsprechend für
Planungssicherheit und es ist doch auch
ihre eigene Argumentation Frau Kollegin
ich darf Sie daran erinnern die sie
sagen sie nehmen vor allem diejenigen in
den Blick mit der Karenzzeit die selber
möglichst schnell aus dieser
Arbeitslosigkeit herausfinden und da
haben sie selber gesagt das sind wenige
Monate bis zur rund einem Jahr und
deswegen ist es genau richtig Sie in
diesem Bereich dann festzuhalten
Performer von den im Bereich der Grünen
ja häufiger gesprochen wird also
deswegen ist es ja richtig dass wir dann
sagen wir knüpfen das an diese an diesen
Bereich an und das zweite betrifft die
Frage der
Verletzungen also es ist schon notwendig
dass Eigenbemühungen dann auch
verlässlich eingefordert werden können
und zwar vom ersten Tag an und deswegen
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass der
kooperationsplan und die Aufforderungen
die auf den kooperationsplan Stufen mit
Rechtsverbindlichkeit versehen werden
können denn nur so können diese
letztendlich auch eingefordert werden
und es ist auch eine Frage der Fairness
dass ich dann auch sagen kann derjenige
den ich unterstütze von dem darf ich
doch auch erwarten dass er entsprechende
Eigenbemühungen hat und deswegen haben
wir dafür gesorgt dass Pflichtverletzung
vom ersten Tag an da sind und richtig
ist im Rahmen des Kompromisses haben wir
die Pflichtverletzungen noch einmal
entsprechend abgestaffelt was die
sanktionsfolge angeht aber auch im
übrigen klargestellt dass derjenige sich
ein Jahr lang auch so verhalten muss
dass es zu keinen weiteren
Pflichtverletzungen kommt wenn er
beispielsweise 30 Prozent und damit das
Maximum an Pflichtverletzungen erreicht
hat und auch das ist eine wichtige
marksignal in diesem Bereich und meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir bewahren das fordern und wollen beim
fördern insgesamt besser werden deswegen
ist es richtig dass jetzt bei dieser
Weiterentwicklung von Hartz IV
Ausbildung und Arbeit entsprechend
gleichgestellt werden der Rechtsrahmen
war im übrigen da in diesem Bereich nie
das Problem denn sie verweisen zwar
immer darauf dass der
vermittlungsvorrang jetzt abgeschafft
wird in ihrem eigenen Gesetzesentwurf
schreiben Sie doch ich zitiere die
bestehenden Regelungen des SGB II
formulieren keinen ausdrücklichen
vermittlungsvorgang Zitat Ende der
Rechtsrahmen war nie das Problem sondern
es ging alleine darum wie die Praxis
damit umgeht und das was die Praxis tut
zeichnen sie nun in ihrem
Gesetzesentwurf nach das ist richtig und
damit setzen wir auch einen deutlichen
Schwerpunkt in diesen Bereichen sie
unterstreichen das auch noch mit mehr
finanziellen Mitteln die notwendig sind
auch mit besseren
hinzuverdienstmöglichkeit werden das ist
wichtig in dem Bereich beschreibt aber
auch die eigentliche Problemlage um die
es in diesem Bereich geht um tatsächlich
Arbeitslose zu motivieren aus der
Arbeitslosigkeit herauszukommen eine
Qualifizierung und eine Ausbildung
entsprechend auch anzugreifen diese
Zielrichtung teilen wir und das ist auch
richtig entscheidend wird allerdings
sein dass die Mittelausstattung der
Jobcenter entsprechend stattfindet all
das was sie in Schaufenster stellen muss
auch Realität in der Praxis werden und
der zeigt sich bei den
eingliederungsmitteln sie kürzen diese
von auf 4 um 400 Teil 400 Millionen Euro
kürzen Sie die eingliederungsmittel sehr
wohl und damit steht weniger Geld zur
Verfügung obwohl wir gleichzeitig
590.000 Ukrainerinnen und kleiner mehr
im System haben die auf Unterstützung
angewiesen sind sie sorgen nicht dafür
mit der notwendigen Mittelausstattung
dass
was sie in das Gesetz schreiben auch
tatsächlich Realität werden muss und das
ist die Aufgabe vor der wir gemeinsam in
diesem Bereich stehen und vor allem sind
vielen herzlichen Dank
Stefan Stracke hat für die Union das
Bürgergeld hauptamtlich mitverhandelt
und das Bürgergeld ist ist und soll ja
das Meisterstück von Hubertus Heil dem
Bundesarbeitsminister werden und er hat
sich gestern nach dem
Vermittlungsausschuss als Letzter vor
die Kameras gestellt und man merkte ihm
auch die Genugtuung an das Hartz 4 nun
endlich abgewickelt werden meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
die Beratung über den Haushalt des
Bundesministeriums zu arbeiten soziales
gibt mal Gelegenheit in diesen Zeiten
nicht nur Danke zu sagen den
haushälteren Haushältern die hart
gearbeitet haben sondern vor allem über
die Prinzipien zu reden nach denen wir
Arbeitsmarkt und Sozialpolitik in
Deutschland gestalten
und das sind Zeiten von Krieg und Krise
und das sind Zeiten fundamentaler
unbrüche die Wirtschaft und Arbeitswelt
verändern was ist das Leitmotiv der
Ampelkoalition von SPD Bündnis 90 den
Grünen und FDP es ist das Motto Chancen
und Schutz denn um beides geht es meine
Damen und Herren es geht darum dass die
Qualität eines Sozialstaates sich zum
einen daran bemisst wie man mit Menschen
umgeht die auf Hilfe und Unterstützung
angewiesen sind aber die Qualität des
Sozialstaates bemisst sich nicht allein
an der Frage der Fähigkeit wie man
Menschen in Not schützen kann sondern
vor allen Dingen an der Qualität des
Sozialstaates Menschen zu einem
selbstbestimmten Leben ohne Abhängigkeit
zu befähigen
und dabei steht für uns der Wert und die
Würde der Arbeit ganz vorne an das ist
der Grund warum die
Bundesregierung gemeinsam mit den
Koalitionsfraktionen dafür gesorgt hat
dass der Mindestlohn steigt seit 1
oktober ist der Mindestlohn in
Deutschland 12 Euro das hilft 6,5
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland arbeit
muss sich lohnen meine Damen und Herren
Arbeit muss den Unterschied machen
und das ist der Grund warum diese
Bundesregierung dafür gesorgt hat mit
den Koalitionsfraktionen gemeinsam dass
wir Menschen mit geringem Einkommen bei
Steuern und Abgaben entlasten damit sie
netto mehr in der Tasche haben damit
Arbeit sich lohnt weil Arbeit den
Unterschied macht meine Damen und Herren
das ist der Grund
warum wir das Wohngeld erhöhen warum wir
auch dafür gesorgt haben dass das
Kindergeld steigt
meine Damen und Herren Arbeit ist mehr
als Brot Erwerb ich bin sehr dankbarer
Stracke dass sie mich ständig zitieren
ich werde nur dankbar dass sie ihre
Fußnoten dann auch überprüfen wenn Sie
das ständig tun wenn wir uns da doch
einig sind Arbeit ist wichtig für den
Zusammenhalt von Gesellschaft weil es
geht um Teilhabe um Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zu haben und was zu leisten und
Teil der Gesellschaft zu sein das ist
das Ziel unserer Politik wer arbeiten
will soll unterstützt werden wir
arbeiten kann muss die Chance in
Deutschland bekommen das ist das Ziel
dieser Koalition meine Mutter
und frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren es ist richtig der
Vermittlungsausschuss hat gestern den
frei gemacht dass das Bürgergeld zum 1
Januar kommen wird Hartz IV wird
Geschichte sein dass Bürgergeld wird zum
ersten Januar in Kraft treten das ist
ein wesentlicher Schritt eine große
Sozialreform die wir gemeinsam stimmen
und auch dabei geht es um Chancen und
Schutz
es geht darum Menschen die Not geraten
sind verlässlich und unbürokratischer
als im hartz4-system abzusichern und das
schafft dieses Gesetz
mit großen Maßnahmen
auch mit der Erhöhung des Regelsatzes
aber auch uns das ist uns nicht genug
unser Ziel bleibt wo immer es möglich
ist Menschen in Arbeit zu bringen ihnen
Chancen auf den selbstbestimmtes Leben
zu öffnen und dafür zu sorgen dass
Arbeit sich lohnt und mit dem Bürgergeld
lohnt sich Arbeit mehr wir sorgen dafür
dass beispielsweise die
Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten großzügiger
werden meine Damen und Herren Arbeit
macht den Unterschied und dabei hilft
auch das
und dieses Bürgergeld sorgt auch dafür
dass wir die Chance geben mehr
qualifizierte Fachkräfte in Deutschland
zu haben im bisherigen System im
Hartz-IV-System sind zwei Drittel der
Langzeitarbeitslosen Menschen ohne
jegliche Berufsausbildung im bisherigen
hartz-iv-systemen kommen die hin und
wieder mal in Hilfsjobs und das
Jobcenter sieht sie nach ein paar
Monaten wieder mit diesen neuen Ansatz
mit dem Bürgergeld setzen wir auf
Weiterbildung und Qualifizierung wir
sorgen dafür dass Menschen ein Abschluss
nachholen können und dauerhaft am
Arbeitsmarkt Fuß zu fassen
und ja ich bin sehr froh und dankbar
dass wir es schaffen werden
voraussichtlich morgen dass der Deutsche
Bundestag in der Bundesrat diese große
soziale Reform mit großen Mehrheiten
beschließt und dazu waren harte
Gespräche und anstrengende Verhandlungen
notwendig ich möchte mich ganz herzlich
bedanken erstmal bei den
Koalitionsfraktionen die den Weg frei
gemacht haben für sozialen Fortschritte
den Bürgergeld aber ich möchte mich auch
bedanken bei den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union namentlich
Karl-Josef Laumann aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen und bei Hermann
Gröhe für harte Gespräche wir haben
gerungen aber ich will sagen ich habe
Respekt davor dass Demokraten bei
einschneidenden Fragen die unsere Nation
betreffen bei großen sozialen Fragen in
der Lage sind Kompromisse zu finden die
Unversöhnlichkeit ist nichts was diese
Gesellschaft auszeichnen darf der
Fortschritt will muss zur Kompromissen
in der Lage sein dafür möchte ich mich
ganz herzlich bedanken
es ist diese große kraftanstrengen wir
zu geführt hat dass die CDU von ihrer
total Blockade abgewichen ist und auch
dafür bedanke
aber bei aller Gemeinsamkeit dass wir
das gemeinsam stemmen ist mir eins
aufgefallen ich habe die Verlautbarung
ihres Fraktionsvorsitzenden wo ist der
übrigens heute gut dass es keine
meldeversäumnisse mit Sanktionen für
Fraktionsvorsitzende gibt uns 10% kürzen
aber unbeschadet spaß beiseite hier ist
eins aufgefallen Herr März hat sehr viel
gesprochen über Begriffe über
Instrumente über die Geschlossenheit der
Union nur eins und das mag der
Unterschied sein hat er nicht getan er
hat niemals über die Menschen gesprochen
um die es geht er hat nicht gesprochen
über alleinerziehende Frauen die auf
ergänzende Grundsicherung Bürgergeld
angewiesen sind falls sie nicht Vollzeit
arbeiten können und das machen wir
einfacher wir unterstützen mit dem
höheren Regelsatz gezielt auch vor allen
Dingen alleinerziehende Frauen und
Kinder er hat nicht gesprochen über
diejenigen die als junge Menschen in
Familien groß geworden sind die nie
Arbeit erlebt haben und die sich
aufgerappelt haben Ausbildung zu machen
im alten Hartz IV-System erlebt haben
dass die Ausbildungsvergütung noch
gekürzt wurde in der sozialen
Unterstützung das macht das Bürgergeld
besser er hat nie gesprochen über
Facharbeiter die nach Jahren hatte
Arbeit unverschuldet ihre Arbeit
verloren haben und auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
keine Chance mehr haben das ändern wir
mit dem Bürger das Geld weil wir den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt entfristen weil
wir Arbeiten ermöglichen
und er hat nie über selbstständige
gesprochen
die mal vorübergehend weil sie Pech
hatten oder weil es Krisen gab auf
ergänzende Grundsicherung angewiesen
sind mit dem Bürgergeld sorgen wir dafür
dass sie nicht vollständig ihrspart ist
auf dem Kopf hauen müssen und dass sie
sich nicht sorgen machen müssen auch
noch ihre Wohnung zu verlieren auch
dieser Fortschritt ist dauerhaft mit dem
Bürgergeld wirklich meine Damen und
Herren
kompromisse sind in der Demokratie
notwendig wenn man sozialen Fortschritt
will und richtig ist es auch dass wir
aufeinander zugehen die Unterschiede
bleiben aber wir koalieren ja nicht
miteinander liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
von der cdu/csu und das ist auch gut so
weil mit dieser Koalition mehr
Fortschritt möglich ist aber eins will
ich Ihnen auch sagen und das ist wichtig
weil es über den Tag hinausgeht nach
vielen Jahren der polarisierten Debatte
und das System der Grundsicherung hat
vier und gerade nach den letzten Wochen
bietet dieser Weg den wir gemeinsam
gefunden haben die Chance eine
gesellschaftliche Polarisierung zu
entgiften ich meine das ganz ernst meine
Damen und Herren wir haben ja seit
Jahren erlebt das ist extreme Positionen
gegeben hat was die Frage von Menschen
in der Grundsicherung Hartz IV gegeben
hat da gab es die
wieso getan haben als da die Mehrheit
oder sogar alle Menschen die bedürftig
sind zu faul zu arbeiten da gab es die
anderen die haben so getan als sei jede
Mitwirkungspflicht schon einen Anschlag
auf die Menschen würde beide extremen
Positionen sind unvernünftig und durch
das Bürgergeld haben wir eine Chance mit
breiter Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag
und im Bundesrat dafür zu sorgen dass
wir eine vernünftiges System nach vorne
entwickelt bekommen aber dass wir durch
eine Entgiftung der Debatte auch einen
Beitrag zum gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt als meine Damen und Herren
denn das braucht unsere Gesellschaft in
Zeiten von Krisen in Zeiten des Wandels
und deshalb will ich abschließend sagen
meine Damen und Herren Chancen und
Schutz das ist das Motto dieser
Bundesregierung und das werden wir
weiterhin der arbeitsmarkt-sozialpolitik
als unser Leitmotiv machen aber
wichtiger als Motti als auch Leitmotive
ist der Blick auf die Lebenswirklichkeit
von Menschen und die verbessern wir mit
unserer Arbeitsmarkt und Sozialpolitik
Schritt für Schritt und jetzt machen wir
einen großen Schritt mit dem Bürgergeld
und morgen haben sie alle die Chance
zuzustimmen herzlichen Dank
Hubertus Heil hat es angesprochen morgen
wird der Bundestag hier ohne Aussprache
dem kommt missergebnis das
Vermittlungsausschusses zustimmen und
dann ist diese Abstimmung auch im
Bundesrat Morgen und dann wird diese
Reform zum ersten ersten greifen dann
heißt es nicht mehr Hartz IV sondern
Bürger Geld und das ist ein wichtiges
Ziel gewesen von Hubertus Heil Rene
Springer jetzt für die AFD
ich möchte mit einem Zitat beginnen von
Ludwig Erhard der mal sagte die
Inflation kommt nicht über uns als ein
Fluch oder als ein tragisches Geschick
sie wird immer durch eine leichtfertige
oder sogar verbrecherische Politik
hervorgerufen ich finde nichts passt
besser in die heutige Zeit als dieser
Satz vom Vater der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft
die Inflation hat aktuell den höchsten
Wert seit fast 50 Jahren erreicht jeder
7 muss sich höher verschulden jeder
zweite sorgt sich inzwischen um sein
Lebensunterhalt die lebensmitteltafeln
verhängen Aufnahmestopps weil sie den
Ansturm nicht mehr bewältigen können
Millionen wissen nicht wie Sie die
nächste Energierechnung bezahlen sollen
und Minister heil und die gesamte
Bundesregierung eben auch die
kartellparteien hier im Parlament sehen
die Schuld dafür bei Putin aber das ist
eben nichts mehr als eine dreiste Lüge
die Inflation lag im dezember 2021 bei
5,3% zu dem Zeitpunkt der höchste Wert
seit 30 Jahren Gemüse kostete 10% mehr
Kraftstoffe 33% Heizöl 60%. zu dem
Zeitpunkt hatte noch kein einziger
russischer Soldat ukrainischen Boden
betreten und das zeigt eben dass das
alles was sie erzählen eine große Lüge
ist
die Verantwortung für die Inflation
liegt nicht bei Putin sondern bei den
kartellparteien sie allein tragen die
Verantwortung dafür dass die
Energiepolitik gescheitert ist dass die
Steuern unerträglich hoch sind in
Deutschland dass unser Wand
wirtschaftlich stark beschädigt wurde
durch die corona-maßnahmen seit einem
Jahrzehnt dulden sie die verbrecherische
Gelddruckerei der EZB und sie alle
Stützen den Wirtschaftskrieg gegen
Russland
Aufgabe aber einer Regierung ist es
nicht unsere Bürger in Armut zu stürzen
und Deutschland wirtschaftlich zu
ruinieren sondern für bezahlbare Energie
zu sorgen und die Ursachen der Inflation
zu bekämpfen und das geht eben nicht mit
billigen Bahntickets und mickrigen
Einmalzahlungen die obendrein auch noch
versteuert werden müssen das geht nur
das geht nur mit einer entschlossenen
Politik nach dem Prinzip Deutschland und
die deutschen Bürger immer zuerst
schluss mit den Sanktionen gegen
Russland Schluss mit der Gelddruckerei
Schluss mit der Abzocke der Steuerzahler
was wir brauchen sind Steuerentlastungen
billiges Gas aus Nordstemmen 2 und ein
sofortigen Wiedereinstieg in die
Kernenergie aber all das
all das verweigern sie stattdessen
treten sie den Bürgern unseres Landes
beim Fallen noch in den Rücken indem sie
aus dem deutschen Sozialstaat ein Mekka
für Migranten machen inzwischen haben 45
Prozent aller Hartz IV Empfänger in
Deutschland keinen deutschen Pass in
Bayern sind es sogar 55 Prozent ich
frage mich warum Hartz IV Bürgergeld
heißen soll wenn die Hälfte der Bezieher
überhaupt keine Bürger unseres Landes
sind
sie sollten das ganze zuwanderungsprämie
nennen dann werden sie näher an der
Wahrheit ab Januar gibt es vom ersten
Tag an 500 Euro auf die Hand dazu Miete
Heizkosten Betriebskosten
Krankenversicherung Geld für Möbel Geld
für Klassenfahrten Befreiung von den
Kita-Gebühren und Befreiung vom
gez-zwangsbeitrag was für ein
Nackenschlag für mindestlohnempfänger
die mit einem 40 Stunden Job kaum mehr
in der Tasche haben am Monatsende als
ein Hartz IV Empfänger
was was für eine Respektlosigkeit
gegenüber 5 Millionen Rentnern in
Deutschland die weniger als 1.000 Euro
monatlich zur Verfügung haben und was
für einen hohen gegenüber Jobcenter
Mitarbeitern die ihrem Gegenüber Miete
und Heizkosten bewilligen müssen die
oftmals über dem liegen was sich die
Jobcenter Mitarbeiter selber noch
leisten können das alles ist einfach nur
noch absurd was sie sich erlauben die
Bild-Zeitung schreibt gestern im
Jobcenter sitzen die Mitarbeiter bei 19
Grad während sich ausländische Hartz IV
wundern warum es dort zu viel kälter ist
als in ihren Wohnungen bei denen werden
die Heizkosten übrigens auch noch vom
Amt übernommen das ist eine irre Politik
die nichts anderes ist als
inländerfeindlich
im kommenden Jahr wird die
Bundesregierung weit mehr als 15
Milliarden Euro für ausländische
bürgergeldempfänger ausgeben für die
Grundrente finden wir im Haushalt gerade
mal eine Milliarde Euro das sagt einfach
alles über die falschen Prioritäten
dieser Bundesregierung
sie reden ständig von Respekt aber sie
sollen Migranten die nie einen Cent ins
Sozialsystem eingezahlt haben mehr
Respekt als den deutschen Rentnern und
den deutschen Steuerzahlern der Vater
der Vater der sozialen Marktwirtschaft
würde heute vermutlich sagen die
Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme kommt
nicht über uns als ein Fluch oder als
ein tragisches Geschick
sie wird immer durch eine leichtfertige
oder sogar verbrecherische Politik
hervorgerufen und ich hoffe dass diese
Bundesregierung und die kartellparteien
hier im Parlament eines Tages dafür zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden danke für
die Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
der Bundestag debattiert in der
haushaltswoche jetzt über den Einzelplan
elf seit heute morgen um 9 Uhr Arbeit
und Soziales und der nächste Redner hier
ist Andreas audritsch für die
Bündnisgrünen erst stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren die wichtigste Nachricht zu
allererst das Bürgergeld kommt es kommt
zum ersten Januar 2023 das bedeutet 50
Euro mehr für die Menschen im Bürgergeld
aber eins ist auch klar dass Bürgergeld
ist viel mehr als nur diese
Regelsatzerhöhung
ich habe mir die Pressekonferenz von
Herrn März angeschaut und das was mich
am meisten erstaunt hat bei dieser
Pressekonferenz war dass er märz nicht
einen einzigen Satz über das Bürgergeld
gesagt hat er hat nicht einen Satz in
der Sache gesagt und er hat und das ist
ein fast noch schlimmer nicht einen Satz
über die Menschen gesagt um diese
eigentlich geht und das sagt etwas über
die Union in den letzten Wochen ging es
vielen von ihnen vor allem den
redelsführern nicht um die Menschen es
ging um Stimmungsmache und das ist das
Problem ihrer Politik in den letzten
Wochen gewesen
ich sage Ihnen was über die Menschen
wenn eine Familie ein Schicksalsschlag
erleidet und Leistungen beantragen muss
dann ist es unter Hartz IV häufig so
gewesen dass das allererste was diese
Menschen tun müssen eine neue Wohnung zu
suchen ist weil die Wohnungen ein
kleines bisschen zu groß war und was
bedeutet das für die Menschen das
bedeutet Kinder aus der Kita nehmen das
bedeutet die Freunde im Umfeld
zurücklassen das bedeutet all das nur
eben nicht sich auf die Jobsuche zur
konzentrieren und genau das ändern wir
jetzt mit dem Bürgergeld die Karenzzeit
von 12 Monaten gibt Menschen genau diese
Chance sich zu konzentrieren auf die
Jobsuche
und wer einmal im Jobcenter war der weiß
auch die ganzen Geschichten darüber dass
Menschen immer wieder in den nächst
schlechtesten im prekäre Jobs geschickt
wurde diesen drehtüreffekt das ist Hartz
IV und genau das schaffen wir jetzt ab
und deswegen
und deswegen schaffen wir einen
Paradigmen
Paradigmenwechsel indem wir sagen in den
Jobcentern wird ab sofort nicht mehr in
den nächst schlechtesten Job vermittelt
sondern es geht um Qualifizierung es
geht um Weiterbildung endlich
finanzieren wir eine dreijährige
Berufsausbildung und oben drauf oben
drauf gibt es 150 €, wenn man sich genau
dafür entscheidet nämlich Fachkraft zu
werden das ist der Kern wir setzen auf
positive Anreize wir setzen darauf dass
Menschen voran kommen wollen und
deswegen ist es ein fundamentaler
Unterschied zu dem was in Hartz 4 noch
gegolten hat und wir setzen auch auf
positive Anreize für Jugendliche was für
eine schreckliche Situation für Kinder
daraus Hartz 4 Familien wenn alle in der
Schule ein Nebenjob machen um am
Wochenende sich was leisten zu können
nur die Hartz IV Kinder müssen alles
abgeben am Ende ein Großteil abgeben
auch das beenden wir wir werden dieses
System beenden weil wir nicht zulassen
und nicht hinnehmen dass Kinder für die
finanzielle Situation ihrer Eltern
bestraft werden das beenden wir und
diesen Geist das den Geist des Zutrauens
und den Geist der Anreize der spiegelt
sich auch bei den Regelungen zu den
Sanktionen wieder wir senken die
Sanktionen massiv mit diesem Gesetz das
Bundesverfassungsgericht lässt 30
Prozent Sanktionen zu wir starten mit
zehn Prozent weil wir nicht darauf
setzen auf maximale Strafe hinaus zu
sein sondern weil wir darauf aus sind
gemeinsam Perspektive und Zukunft zu
entwickeln
die Verbesserungen des Bürgergeldes
werden zum ersten Januar kommen
und das trotz einer Kampagne die in den
letzten Wochen mit brutaler Kälte gegen
Menschen in der Grundsicherung geführt
wurde mich hat diese Kälte gerade von
Seiten der Union in den letzten Monaten
in den letzten Wochen schockiert das
muss ich Ihnen sagen wenn es nur noch
darum geht die Gesellschaft gegen arme
Menschen aufzuwickeln hat das nichts mit
einem christlichen Menschenbild zu tun
das was wir machen ist weiter zu kämpfen
für arme Menschen das ist was wir machen
ist zusammenzuarbeiten mit den Kirchen
mit den Gewerkschaften mit den
Wohlfahrtsverbänden und mit den Menschen
die selber in Armut leben müssen wir
kämpfen weiter für eine andere
gerechtere Gesellschaft mit den Menschen
zusammen das ist unsere grüne Agenda und
die werden wir auch in Zukunft
fortsetzen herzlichen Dank
Andreas auditsch nutze seine Redezeit um
sich hier an der Union abzuarbeiten
gestern gab es einen Kompromiss im
Vermittlungsausschuss ohne die Union und
diesen Kompromiss würde das Bürgergeld
nicht am ersten Januar in Kraft treten
können Matthias Birg weil jetzt für die
Linke Sprecher für Renten und
alterssicherungs-
lieber Bundesminister Hubertus Heil 1991
wurden bestimmte Rentenansprüche aus
DDR-Zeiten nicht in das bundesdeutsche
Rentensystem übernommen zu Unrecht
wir linken fordern seit 30 Jahren das
beispielsweise ehemalige Eisenbahner
Postler Ballettänzerinnen und in der DDR
geschiedene Frauen Gerechtigkeit zu Teil
werden muss und ihre Ansprüche für die
sie Beiträge gezahlt haben
berücksichtigt werden mögen
[Applaus]
dass sie mit dem härtefallfonds endlich
das Renten Unrecht Ost anerkennen mehr
Lob gibt es leider nicht denn einmalig
und insgesamt nur extrem bescheidene 500
Millionen Euro für ostdeutsche deren
Rentenansprüche nicht anerkannt wurden
für Spätaussiedler und die jüdischen
Kontingentflüchtlinge aus der
Sowjetunion sind nur ein sehr schlechter
Witz
eine Einmalzahlung von gerade einmal
2500 Euro wird keiner dieser betroffenen
Gruppen auch nur im Ansatz gerecht auf
eine durchschnittliche Rentenbezugsdauer
sind das umgerechnet nur zehn Euro 42 im
Monat Martin Rosemann und da sollten Sie
sich schämen denn das ist beschämen und
für 100000 Menschen respektlos und
demütigen ich fordere die
Bundesregierung darum auf gewähren sie
erstens die Einmalzahlung nicht nur den
Bedürftigen denn hier geht es um Respekt
vor der Lebensleistung von ostdeutschen
und aus der Sowjetunion zugewanderte
Juden und Aussiedler und machen Sie
zweitens aus dem härtefallfonds einen
gerechtigkeitsfonds und da hören sie die
Einmalzahlung auf mindestens 10.000 Euro
die Finanzierung dafür kann ich Ihnen
gerne nennen
verzichten Sie auf die zehn Milliarden
Euro zockergeld der FDP für die
sogenannte aktienrente
meine Damen und Herren sie wollen
ernsthaft die 10 Milliarden Euro für
ihre überflüssige aktienrente auf
punktfinanzieren und das bei massiv
steigenden Anleihezinsen und
gleichzeitig sinkenden Aktienkursen die
aktienrente kommt nur dann ins Plus wenn
die Renditen die Kreditzinsen
übersteigender Studien doch jede
sparkassenberaterin den Kopf zocken ist
kein Konzept für stabile und sichere
Renten Finanzen darum lassen sie das
sorgen Sie für ein dauerhaft höheres
Rentenniveau mehr tarifliche Entlohnung
Sozialversicherungspflicht ab der ersten
Arbeitsstunde und für echte Arbeitgeber
finanzierte Betriebsrenten sorgen Sie
dafür dass wir freiwillige zusätzliche
Einzahlung möglich machen die IG Metall
nennt das so die Rente ich bin für mehr
Soli Rente statt aktienrente herzlichen
Dank
so und der nächste Sinnes Pascal Kober
von der FDP jetzt Sprecher für
Arbeitsmarkt und Sozialpolitik der
Liberalen
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen für die Arbeitsmarkt und
Sozialpolitik werden im kommenden Jahr
163,3 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung
stellen das ist die größte Summe die der
Bundeshaushalt für einen einzelnen
politischen Arbeitsbereich zur Verfügung
stellt und diese
163,3 Milliarden Euro die die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler für
die Arbeitsmarkt und Sozialpolitik zur
Verfügung stellen ist bei ihnen mit
einer Hoffnung verbunden natürlich auf
der einen Seite dass wir den Menschen
die im Laufe ihres Lebens Straucheln
unter die Arme greifen aber vor allen
Dingen auch dass wir Sie unterstützen
und ihn wieder aufhelfen um
Selbstständigkeit und freies Leben als
Bürger wieder zu unterstützen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und das machen wir genau mit diesem
bürgergeldgesetz das jetzt im kommenden
Jahr Gesetz werden wird das geht genau
in diese Richtung es geht nicht nur um
die Erhöhung von Regelsätzen die richtig
ist weil es dabei um den
Inflationsausgleich geht sondern es geht
vor allen Dingen um mehr Vorankommen um
mehr Chancen und um mehr Motivation es
geht um ein positives Menschenbild und
ich bin da sehr sehr froh dass dieses
Bürgergeld diesen neuen Geist in sich
aufnimmt und dass wir in Zukunft die
Menschen wieder viel viel stärker von
ihren Potenzialen her begreifen werden
von dem was sie können was in ihnen
steckt statt von dem sie von der Seite
anzusprechen was Sie vielleicht nicht
können oder was sie im Moment noch nicht
sind liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wir wollen auch Motivation im
Sozialstaat und deshalb werden wir die
Zuverdienstgrenzen in einem ersten
Schritt schon mal nach oben führen das
ist Leistungsgerechtigkeit weil ob
jemand sich schwer tut im Arbeitsmarkt
oder es leicht hat wer viel verdient
oder wenig verdient
Leistungsgerechtigkeit seine Form der
Gerechtigkeit die jedem in diesem Land
zusteht und hier gehen wir einen Schritt
nach vorne
und Leistungsgerechtigkeit ist auch eine
Investition in die Zukunft
wir wollen damit Schluss machen dass
junge Menschen mit unter die aller Zeit
Arbeitslosigkeit ihrer Eltern Erben
müssen wir werden den jungen Menschen
besser fördern als bisher und auch
dadurch dass wir ihnen gerecht werden
denn ein junger Mensch der
beispielsweise eine Ausbildungsvergütung
von 800 Euro bekommt hat bisher in der
von der CDU unterstützen Systematik nur
240 Euro davon behalten dürfen er darf
künftig 6004 Euro erhalten ich verstehe
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Union warum sie dazu in der
Vergangenheit nie bereit waren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
da haben sie hart zugegriffen und das
hat auch damit dazu geführt dass viele
gar nicht die Motivation hatten eine
Ausbildung zu beginnen damit machen wir
jetzt Schluss unsere Sozialstaat muss
aufstiegsorientierter werden er wird es
mit dem Bürgergeld er muss motivierender
werden er wird es mit dem Bürgergeld er
wird chancenreicher werden er wird es
mit diesem Bürgergeld vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Pascal kuba hat es angesprochen also das
Bürgergeld morgen wird es verabschiedet
im Bundestag und im Bundesrat ist
eingestellt im Bereich Arbeit und
Soziales mit
23,76 Milliarden Euro das sind ungefähr
2,5 Milliarden mehr als in diesem Jahr
und Peter auch immer jetzt der nächste
Redner für Junioren über Prinzipien zu
diskutieren über Prinzipien die unser
Land in den letzten 70 Jahren getragen
haben der Sozialstaat und die soziale
Marktwirtschaft sie in der
Ampel-Koalition meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren sehen leider das und
dazwischen relativ stark und vergessen
dass wir Sozialstaat und soziale
Marktwirtschaft gemeinsam sehen müssen
und ich teile Ihre Einschätzung dass
Schutz und Chance in einer gemeinsamen
Verbindung gesehen werden Herr Minister
aber leider haben sie und die Redner
ihre Ampelkoalition heute auch
Prinzipien hin anstehen lassen wenn man
die reden lieber von Ihnen Herr Kurt von
ihnen anhört dann glaube ich merkt man
sehr deutlich dass es diese Richtung die
Sache geht sondern dass sie gemerkt
haben dass die Mehrheit der Menschen in
diesem Land nicht denken wie Sie dass
wir nicht vergessen haben die
Lebensleistung der Menschen zu schätzen
sondern dass sie in ihrem
Regierungshandeln die Mehrheit der
Menschen nicht hinter sich haben und das
ist in ihren Reden sehr deutlich
geworden
beim Bürgergeld und das nochmal
aufzugreifen meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren ist es der Ampel vor allem
darum gegangen ein Trauma zu bewältigen
hat vier muss weg den Einstieg in ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen zu
schaffen und bei der FDP war
Totalausfall die Anrechnungen die sind
denke ich relativ gut aber beim Rest
haben sie einfach mitgemacht ohne zu
schauen welche Auswirkungen das für die
Wirtschaft in unserem Land hat meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
gerade in der Zeit in der wir leben
müssen wir stärker auf die Verbindung
von Sozialstaat und soziale
Marktwirtschaft schauen wir müssen die
Drohne Rezessionen die steigende
Inflation den Arbeits- und
Fachkräftemangel in den Blick nehmen
aber auch die Situation der
Sozialsysteme in unserem Land ich möchte
drei Beispiele aus dem Haushalt nennen
einmal Herr Heil sie haben vorher so
getan als wäre das Bürgergeld die Lösung
für alles ich glaube es wird sehr
deutlich dass es das nicht ist wenn man
dann in den Haushalt schaut Herr kurz
sie haben gesagt sie würden gerne über
viele Themen reden genau diese Themen
über diese reden wollten die für ich an
sie kürzen im Haushalt den
Eingliederungstitel in Arbeit
beträchtlich und sagen dann nach uns
geht es bei Bürgergeld ja darum dass man
den Menschen stärker in Arbeit bekommt
dass man sie ausbildet wir haben als
große Koalition den Menschen die
Möglichkeit gegeben mit dem sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt langfristig auch Menschen
die Förderung brauchen zu integrieren
sie kürzen diesen Titel und das denke
ich ist fast schon schäbig wenn man die
Debatte vorher hört
wenn man
Kollege einmal weiterschauen nein danke
wir können dann später diskutieren jetzt
bringt es glaube ich relativ wenig sie
haben die Zeit gehabt in ihrer Rede
haben das nicht getan haben nur auf uns
geschimpft und dann müssen sie das auch
anhören die
Haushaltstitel berufliche Integration
und Beratung von Zuwanderern und die
berufsbezogene Deutsch Sprachförderung
wird gekürzt meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren der Ampel bei 600.000
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen die in das
grundsicherungssystem kommen ist auch
das unverantwortungslos und ich glaube
sie widersprechen ihrer Politik da
deutlich und ein letztes Beispiel es ist
vorher schon angesprochen worden die
aktienrente hoch gelobt ja von der FDP
in diesem Haushalt wieder nichts zu
finden es ist ja mittlerweile
angekündigt dass es über
Kredite finanzieren wollen wenn man dann
liest dass die Rente Enkel fit sein soll
dann glaube ich zeigt es auch ein klein
bisschen den Widerspruch ihrer Arbeit
und wenn man dann die F
angepressemeldung zur aktienrente liest
dass das vielleicht die größte
Rentenreform seit Bismarck sein soll
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
hätte Bismarck gearbeitet wie sieht es
tun dann wäre der Sozialstaat nicht auf
starken Säulen wie es heute ist
oder nicht zuletzt wenn die Rednerin der
FDP liebe Frau Raffel wischen das hat
nichts mit Anstand zu tun sondern mit
Wahrheit meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren und nicht zuletzt wenn sie dann
noch die Kürzungen beim
transformationsprojekt Arbeitswelt im
Wandel jetzt große herausstellen dass
sie da über 10 Millionen Euro gestrichen
haben dann glaube ich ist es in einer
Zeit wo unsere Wirtschaft bei einer
großen Transformation steht auch etwas
was für die FDP spricht was zeigt das
ihnen Zukunftsprojekte weniger wichtig
sind als der Titel in ihrer Koalition
fortschrittskoalition zu sein meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren reicht nicht
aus wenn man unserem Land keine Zukunft
gibt meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren für uns steht fordern und fördern
als ganz wesentlicher Punkt und ich
hätte mir die letzten Wochen sehr
intensiv gedacht warum man da so
streiten kann weil eigentlich ist dieser
Begriff ja Inbegriff dessen was
Deutschland in die letzten in den
letzten Jahrzehnten stark gemacht hat
fordern und fördern bedeutet die
Verbindung von so Vater hat und sozialer
Marktwirtschaft wir als Union haben in
den letzten Jahren ganz ganz intensiv
Wert darauf gelegt und auch in den
letzten Wochen und haben unseren Beitrag
dazu geleistet dass dieser Maßstab immer
im Fokus geblieben ist herzlichen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
bevor ich den nächsten Redner Aufrufe
hat das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention
der Kollege Markus Kurt aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ich darf Ihnen auch als Berichterstatter
für die Grünen für den Einzelplan 11 für
diesen Haushalt doch noch ein paar
Fakten mitgeben die sie glaube ich nicht
so richtig mitbekommen haben und auch
der Herr Stracke nicht eben in seiner
Rede was den Eingliederungstitel
anbelangt und den verwaltungskostentitel
ist es richtig dass es eine Kürzung um
650 Millionen Euro gegeben hat im
Entwurf für 2023 gegenüber 2022 wenn Sie
genau nachsehen dann stellen sie fest
dass der verwaltungstitel um 200
Millionen erhöht worden ist der
Eingliederungstitel wiederum und 200
Millionen und das drittens 100 Millionen
dann im Einzelplan 60 ebenfalls mit
Bezug auf die eingliederungsmittel
eingestellt worden sind macht zusammen
500 Millionen bleibt ein Delta von 150
Millionen das aber wenn wir sehen dass
in den vergangenen Jahren immer
ausgabereste da waren geschlossen werden
kann durch ein vernünftigen
Mittelabfluss und durch eine vernünftige
mittelbewirtschaftung unterjährig worauf
wir alle als ampelhaushälter achten
werden dann haben sie
dann haben sie den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt angesprochen
und beklagt es sei da zu wenig ich darf
daran erinnern dass es die Union war die
in der vergangenen Legislaturperiode bei
der Einführung des
teilhabechancengesetzes dieses befristet
hat und was wir morgen machen werden ist
dass wir das entfristen
und und zu guter Letzt zu guter Letzt
haben Sie hier einen im Vergleich zu den
groß erscheinenden gesamteta 10
Millionen genannt die wir bei dem bei
der Titelgruppe Arbeitswelt im Wandel
gekürzt haben und da darf ich Ihnen das
einfach nur erklären dass wir als
verantwortungsvolle Haushälter Frau
Raffel hat es auch genannt natürlich
darauf achten ist ein ausreichender
Mittelabfluss da und da wo Mittel
Bewirtschaftung Spielräume lässt da
werden wir natürlich auch vernünftig und
mit Augenmaß das ganze koeffizienz
Gesichtspunkten durchforsten danke schön
dass sie dazugelassen haben über die
Zeit Frau Präsident Entschuldigung ja
das heißt Kurzintervention
sie dürfen Stellung nehmen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr Kurt
sie hätten eigentlich in ihrer Rede
Möglichkeit gehabt all diese Dinge zu
besprechen sie haben fünf Minuten oder
sechs Minuten genutzt um auf die CDT zu
schimpfen das
zeigt auch wie wenig Argumente sie haben
vielleicht ganz kurz zu den Punkten wir
hatten ein sehr intensives Gespräch mit
Andrea Nahles
und sie hat gesagt dass alleine der
Titel wenn er nicht gekürzt worden wäre
mit den ukrainischen Flüchtlingen nicht
ausgereicht hätte also sie hätten nicht
nur die Kürzung rückgängig machen müssen
sondern sie hätten sogar aufstocken
müssen und wenn Sie jetzt mit der
Verwaltungskosten kommen dann sollten
Sie doch bitte einmal schauen dass auch
bei der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
Inflation ein wichtiger Punkt ist also
auch die 200 Millionen die reichen da
auch nicht aus deswegen deswegen Herr
Kurt bleiben Sie dabei der Wahrheit und
schauen Sie dass Sie dieses wesentlich
wichtige Feld für die Integration von
ausländischen Menschen von Zuwanderern
auch dementsprechend verantwortungsvoll
finanziell ausstatten und zum Thema
Arbeitswelt im Wandel des sollte der
kompletten Regierung zu denken geben
wenn man die Mittel die da sind für die
Transformation der Wirtschaft nicht
ausschöpft und sieht es dann begründen
weil nicht ausgesetzt müssen wir kürzen
ist denke ich auch ein Widerspruch in
sich dann soll das
Bundesarbeitsministerium dann soll das
Bundesarbeitsministerium da stärker
arbeiten und Impulse geben das glaube
ich wäre viel wichtiger
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion dr
Martin Rosemann
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren in der letzten
Sitzungswoche bei der Debatte über das
Bürgergeld habe ich Ihnen gesagt wir
werden die Jobcenter mit den notwendigen
Mitteln ausstatten und jetzt beschließen
wir ein Erhöhung der Mittel für die
Jobcenter von 500 Millionen Euro wären
die Union des Thema Jobcenter und
eingliederungsmittel immer nur dann
entdeckt wenn sie in der Opposition ist
hält die Ampel Wort
meine Damen und Herren
das Bürgergeld kann kommen des
Bürgergeld kommt Hartz IV ist Geschichte
und ich muss Ihnen schon sagen Herr
Gröhe sie haben vor zwei Wochen noch im
Interviews gesagt das Gesetz wird
scheitern jetzt stimmen sie morgen zu
schön dass sie dazu gelernt haben
und natürlich natürlich
[Musik]
müssen wir Kompromisse machen das gilt
vor allem für das Thema
Karenzzeit und Schonvermögen aber es
bleibt bei dem was die Ampel hier
vorgelegt hat nämlich bei mehr Respekt
für Lebensleistung auch wenn sie von der
Union das nicht wollten es macht einen
Unterschied ob jemand immer gearbeitet
hat und was uns sich was erspart hat
oder nicht
meine Damen und Herren auch alle anderen
Kernpunkte des Bürgergelds die ich in
der vergangenen Sitzungswoche hier von
diesem Pult angesprochen habe bleiben
ebenfalls bestehen es bleibt bei mehr
Augenhöhe und damit bei einem neuen
Umgang zwischen Staat und Bürgern der
kooperationsplan wird auf Augenhöhe
gemeinsam vereinbart und wenn das nicht
klappt dann kann die Schlichtungsstelle
angerufen werden es bleibt
bei mir Zielgenauigkeit beim fordern und
da müssen wir vielleicht mal jetzt ein
bisschen aufklären Herr Stracke
also Mitwirkungspflichten von Beginn an
nach Antragstellung ab dem ersten Tag
die waren schon im bisherigen Entwurf
drin und dabei bleibt es auch und dabei
bleibt es auch nein wer wer nein wir
lesen kann ist klar im Vorteil dabei
bleibt es auch und es bleibt auch
Bundes bleibt auch dabei dass wer von
Beginn an mitwirkt nicht sofort mit
Sanktionen bedroht wird und es bleibt
auch dabei dass wir aus gesundheitlichen
Gründen nicht mitwirken kann dass der
entsprechend unterstützt wird dabei
bleibt es und das noch richtig so
und es bleibt es bleibt bei mir fördern
mit dem umfassenden Coaching der
Entfristung des sozialen Arbeitsmarkts
der aufsuchenden Arbeit in
Weiterbildungsgeld und den Bürger
geldbuß sorgen wir für bessere
individuelle und passgenaue
Unterstützung und es bleibt bei mehr
Nachhaltigkeit wir schaffen den
vermittlungsvorgang ab
passgenaue nachhaltige Vermittlungen
statt schnelle Vermittlung in irgendeine
Arbeit ist die Devise
also
schließlich bleibt es bei mehr
Leistungsgerechtigkeit beim Zuverdienst
haben junge Leute in Zukunft mehr damit
sie die Erfahrung machen können dass ich
Arbeit auch lohnt die Ampel meine Damen
und Herren sorgt für sozialen
Zusammenhalt in der Krise und für
soziale Sicherheit in Zeiten des
Umbruchs Jule never walk alone das geht
in der Energiekrise genauso wie im
Strukturwandel alle sollen gut durch
diesen Winter kommen die Unternehmen
ihre Beschäftigten und deren Familien
auch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger die auf
Grundsicherung angewiesen sind dafür
führen wir eine gaspreisbremse eine
fernwärme-bremse eine strompreisbremse
ein und dafür erhöhen wir den Regelsatz
meine Damen und Herren
vor allem
vor allem entlasten wir diejenigen die
sich anstrengen die arbeiten und
trotzdem keinen dicken Geldbeutel haben
das Gebiete der Respekt vor deren
Leistung wir senken die
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge für
Niedrigverdiener wir erhöhen das
Kindergeld für alle Kinder auf 250 Euro
wir erhöhen den Kinderzuschlag wir
machen die größte wohngeldreform Erhöhen
des Wohngeld und weitens aus und wir
haben den Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro erhöht
und sorgen damit dafür dass Arbeit und
Leistung den Unterschied machen
und
wer will
wer will dass ich leistung lohnt der
hätte für 12 Euro Mindestlohn Stimmen
sollen das haben sie nicht gemacht
meine Damen und Herren die Ampel sorgt
für soziale Sicherheit und sozialen
Fortschritt in Zeiten der Veränderungen
deshalb werden wir auch dafür sorgen
dass das Rentenniveau über 2025 hinaus
stabil bleibt wir sorgen dafür dass alle
durch die Energie und die
mobilitätswende gute Perspektiven haben
und deshalb werden wir die Beschäftigten
im Strukturwandel noch wirkungsvoller
bei der Weiterbildung unterstützen wir
werden ein Weiterbildungspaket vorlegen
damit die Beschäftigten von heute die
Arbeit von morgen machen können
und
wir werden alles dafür tun
dass die notwendigen Fachkräfte in
diesem Strukturwandel verfügbar sind
damit die Energiewende gelingt und damit
die sozialen Dienstleistungen die diese
Gesellschaft zu dringend braucht denken
Sie an Pflege und an Kinderbetreuung
dass die auch wirklich erbracht werden
können deshalb wird diese Ampelkoalition
ein Einwanderungsgesetz vorlegen was
diesen Namen auch verdient Einwanderung
ist notwendig aber reicht nicht aus
genauso wichtig sind inländische
Potenziale unter Frauen durch bessere
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf und
der Langzeitarbeitslosen deshalb ist es
Bürgergeld mit seiner Priorität auf
individuelle Förderung zielgenau
Weiterbildung und nachhaltige
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
wichtig und unter älteren deshalb
schaffen wir die Hinzuverdienstgrenzen
ab für Leute die vorzeitig in die Rente
gehen und machen ein Programm für
gesunde Arbeit Stärken Prävention und
Reha damit beschäftigte länger gesund im
Arbeitsleben bleiben können insgesamt
meine Damen und Herren sorgt die Ampel
für sozialen Zusammenhalt Respekt vor
der Lebensleistung und sozialen
Fortschritt dafür steht dieser Haushalt
Martin Rosemann war das für die SPD der
Bundestag debattiert über den Einzelplan
11 Arbeit und Soziales und der Sprecher
für Arbeit und Soziales der
bündnisgründen frank zirke hat als
nächster das Wort Präsident Abgeordnete
zudem mit Ignoranz und Lügen durch
tränken schäbigkeitswettbewerb
in der jetzt in den vergangenen Wochen
die Herren märz und Söder gestürzt haben
mit der AFD
hat der Arbeitsminister alles
Erforderliche gesagt ich will mich
deshalb auf den Haushalt konzentrieren
der enthält gegenüber der ursprünglichen
Vorlage wichtige Veränderungen den
Jobcentern werden 200 Millionen Euro
zusätzlich an Verwaltungskosten zur
Verfügung gestellt und der
Eingliederungstitel wird de facto um 300
Millionen Euro aufgestockt ich begrüße
das ausdrücklich
es ist mit Blick auf die
bürgergeldreform zwingend notwendig wir
wollen nämlich mit dem Bürgergeld eine
neue Sozialpolitik einleiten die Agenda
2010 entgiften und eine neue Kultur des
Förderns an die Stelle von Hartz 4
setzen
Mitwirkungspflichten das auch weiterhin
geben ebenso wie die Möglichkeit zu
Leistungsminderung aber der Geist der
Geist des neuen Systems soll nicht der
von Misstrauen sein sondern von
Ermutigung und Befähigung von Hilfe zur
gesellschaftlichen Teilnahme
das fördern wird verstärkt ohne das
fordern aufzugeben
entscheidend wird sein dass im
Einvernehmen auf Augenhöhe im
kooperationsplan ein in die Zukunft
gerichteter Weg vereinbart wird der den
Menschen eine Perspektive auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt erschließt keine Frage die
Einführung des Bürgergeldes stellt die
Jobcenter vor große Herausforderungen
die neuen Aufgaben werden mit dem
bisherigen personalkörpern nicht
durchführbar sein deshalb ist es
folgerichtig jetzt auch die
Verwaltungskosten anzupassen und
zusätzliche personelle und finanzielle
Ressourcen einzuplanen wir tragen dem
unabhängig von ihrem Geschrei mit
verbesserten Haushaltsansätzen ebenso
Rechnung wie mit der Bereitstellung von
2,4 Milliarden Euro für das Bürgergeld
darüber hinaus
heben wir die Mittel für die Kosten der
Unterkunft um 400 Millionen Euro an und
stocken auch den Haushaltsansatz für die
berufliche Integration und Beratung von
zuwandernden um 26 Millionen Euro für
die Jahre 24 und 25 in Form von
Verpflichtungsermächtigungen auf das ist
Ausdruck des manifesten Interesses an
der Gewinnung ausländischer Fachkräfte
für einen naked in Germany
und verändert geblieben
gegenüber dem Haushaltsentwurf ist
hingegen der Ansatz für berufsbezogene
Sprachförderung mit einer Kürzung von
140 Millionen Euro gegenüber vor Jahren
und das obwohl die Zahl der an
sprachförderkursen teilnehmende nicht
zuletzt in Folge der hohen Zahl aus der
Ukraine geflüchteter absehbar ansteigen
dürfte und auch die Honorare der
Lehrkräfte angehoben werden müssen
andernfalls will es immer schwieriger
qualifizierte Fachkräfte zu gewinnen
Sprachförderung ist für eine gelingende
Integration ausländischer Arbeitskräfte
von zentraler Bedeutung hierzu so steht
es in den Eckpunkten zur Fachkräfte
Einwanderung wollen wir Zitat im Inland
die im Ausland die für das
Gesamtprogramm nötigen Haushaltsmittel
erhöhen
vor diesem Hintergrund überrascht es
dass das Bundesarbeitsministerium den
Haushaltsansatz für berufsbezogene
Sprachförderung für auskömmliche erklärt
hat obwohl der gegenüber Vorjahr um 140
Millionen Euro gekürzt wird das ist umso
überraschender als auch dich als auch
die vom Kabinett beschlossene
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
besagt das Zitat die berufssprachkurse
stärker gefördert und deren Mittel
verstehtigt werden damit ist
insbesondere auch eine deutliche
Ausweitung der Sprachkurs Zugangs
verbunden Zitat Ende was ja auch Sinn
macht wenn im Oktober des Jahres allein
600 9000 € ukrainische StaatsbürgerInnen
bei der BA gemeldet waren für die
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt
sprachförderangebote eine wichtige Hilfe
sein können es wird also weiter zu
verfolgen sein ob die nun vorgesehenen
Mittel tatsächlich ausreichend werden
oder ist unterjährig eine ausstockung
von einer überplanmäßigen Ausgabe Bedarf
und wie sich der Mittelabfluss auch in
anderen haushaltstiteln gestaltet
insgesamt setzt die Ampel mit diesem
Haushalt eine Reihe weiterer positive
Akzente unter anderem für die nationale
Armutskonferenz für die Umsetzung der
UN-Behindertenrechtskonvention sowie den
härtefallfonds für jüdische
konvergenzflüchtlinge und Ost-
[Applaus]
frank sirske war das für die Grünen
166,2,3 Milliarden Euro umfasst der
Etagen Arbeit und Soziales das ist mehr
als ein Drittel des Gesamtetats des
Bundeshaushaltes und 5,3 Milliarden Euro
zusätzlich zum vergangenen Jahr jetzt
Ottilie klein für Junioren
fast jeder vierte über 80-jährige in
unserem Land ist von Armut betroffen die
Ampelkoalition das haben wir ja heute
auch wieder gehört die hält sich ja
gerne für soziale als alle anderen hat
aber auf Altersarmut überhaupt keine
Antworten denn wer ein Blick in den
Koalitionsvertrag wird der wird
feststellen dass Altersarmut mit keinem
einzigen Wort erwähnt wird
immerhin
immerhin erwähnt wird im
Koalitionsvertrag dass sie liebe
ampelfraktionen den unter
unionsgeführter Bundesregierung
geplanten härtefallfonds umsetzen wollen
der vorrichtet sich an Härtefälle aus
der
ost-rentenüberleitung Spätaussiedler und
jüdische Zuwanderer und Salz
CDU-Fraktion war und ist es ein
Herzensanliegen die Menschen die sehr
kleine Renten beziehen zu unterstützen
deshalb hat die unionsgeführte Regierung
seinerzeit eine Milliarde Euro in den
Bundeshaushalt 2022 eingestellt
gemeinsam mit Ihnen liebe SPD gaben wir
den Betroffenen die jahrelang um
Anerkennung gekämpft haben das
Versprechen einer finanziellen Hilfe
leider mussten wir feststellen dass sie
ihr Wort gebrochen haben denn den
Beitrag des Bundes hat die Ampel um die
Hälfte gekürzt um 500 Millionen Euro
ausgerechnet
ausgerechnet in einer Zeit in der die
Menschen mit kleinen Renten besonders
belastet sind deshalb haben wir sie auch
aufgefordert die Streichung der Mittel
zurückzunehmen und den härtefallfonds
umzusetzen und das wissen wir an das
gehört zur Wahrheit dazu fast wäre der
härtefallfonds sogar ganz gescheitert
der eilig erstellte halbherzige
Vorschlag für den sie sich nun hier
feiern lassen ist für die Betroffenen
übrigens alles andere als feierlich im
Gegenteil ihre Pläne haben ihre Pläne
haben das Potenzial den Frust der
Betroffenen noch weiter zu erhöhen der
Beitrag bleibt hinter den Erwartungen
zurück eine Beteiligung der Länder ist
weiter unter die Fristen sind viel zu
kurz und sie bringen sogar fertig die
Gruppen gegeneinander auszuspielen und
ungleich zu behandeln das meine Damen
und Herren das ist respektlos gegenüber
der Lebensleistung der Menschen denn wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dieser Form ist
auch Anerkennung und Gerechtigkeit für
jene Menschen die Benachteiligung und
Diskriminierung fahren mussten Menschen
die aufgrund ihrer bewegten Biografien
nur sehr kleine Renten erhalten und von
Altersarmut bedroht sind ihnen ein Stück
weit Anerkennung zu geben das war unser
gemeinsames versprechen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen da auch im
Haushalt 2023 die Kürzung des
bundesanteils nicht zurückgenommen wurde
halte ich fest dass die Ampel dieses
Versprechen gebrochen hat und damit
erneut unter Beweis stellt dass ihr
Altersarmut egal ist vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin für die SPD-Fraktion dr
Tanja machalet
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
was wir jetzt in der Debatte wieder
feststellen konnten war dass die CDU
zwar immer wieder sagt wogegen sie ist
und was sie alles nicht wollen aber sie
haben man ganz wenigen Punkten gesagt
was sie tatsächlich wollen und das
durchzieht alle Debatten die wir bisher
haben das möchte ich nur noch mal
festhalten
und ich möchte auch noch mal deutlich
machen am Einzelplan 11 wird sehr
deutlich wie stark unsere Kolleginnen
und Kollegen im Haushaltsausschuss sich
ins Zeug gelegt haben um den guten
Entwurf noch besser zu machen und
als größter Einzelplan des gesamten
Bundeshaushalts spiegelt er die
Leistungsfähigkeit unseres Sozialstaats
wieder und das ist gerade in dieser Zeit
ein ganz ganz wichtiges Signal
meine Kollegin Katrin michel hat es
treffen vorhin beschrieben Zusammenhalt
in der Zeitenwende bedeutet dass wir
gerade in Krisenzeiten in den
Sozialstaat investieren und wohl
überlegte Ausgaben für die soziale
Sicherung und ein stabilen Arbeitsmarkt
tätigen das ist ein schöner Ersatz und
den kann man glaube ich nicht oft genug
wiederholen im Sinne des Zusammenhalts
möchte ich natürlich auch an dieser
Stelle noch mal auf den Härtefall
Härtefall für Menschen aus der
ost-rentenüberleitung für jüdische
Kontingent Flüchtlinge und spät
Aussiedler eingehen wir stellen im Bund
500 € 500 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung
besser wären natürlich eine Milliarde
ich bin im Haushaltsausschuss aber
dankbar dass es dass er das Gründen
einer Stiftung jetzt endlich ermöglicht
mit der wir nun endlich auszahlen können
und vor allem möchte ich
Bundesarbeitsminister Hubertus Heil an
dieser Stelle nochmal danke dass Sie
sich in den vergangenen Jahren und
insbesondere auch der parlamentarischen
Staatssekretärin Krise dass sie sich
wirklich in den letzten Jahren intensiv
damit befasst haben und wirklich dafür
gekämpft haben das ganze endlich zum
Abschluss zu bringen
das Ministerium
ist jetzt schon bei der Umsetzung das
ist auch wichtig weil wir wissen die
Zeit drängt und ich möchte auch noch mal
an die Bundesländer appellieren die
Katrin michel hat vorhin auch getan
beteiligen Sie sich an den
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern das tut lieber
Kollege birkwald könnte außer ein Teil
dazu beitragen und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus der CDU sie können auch
noch mal gerne mit ihren Ministerinnen
Ministerpräsidenten sprechen das ist gut
ist ich spreche auch mit meiner
Ministerpräsidentin sie können das auch
tun vielleicht kommen die Länder ja noch
zu dem Schluss dass es durchaus auch
ihre Aufgabe ist sich an diesem Fond zu
beteiligen
zum Bürgergeld ist ja nun eine denke ich
alles diskutiert wir werden es morgen
beschließen ich möchte aber trotzdem
noch mal einen Satz dazu sagen und zwar
ein Zitat von Regine Hildebrandt die
übermorgen leider schon seit 21 Jahren
tot ist sie hat gesagt und ich zitiere
mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin aber kurz
ein Alltag ohne soziale Demütigung das
ist das Grundrecht aller ausnahmslos das
ist unsere Haltung das bleibt unsere
Haltung und das ist genau das was uns
von Ihnen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der CDU und insbesondere von Ihnen Herr
Merz unterscheidet herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Axel knörig
und Axel köring für die cdu/csu ist der
letzte Redner hier beim Einzelplan 11
Arbeit und zu cialis liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren
Herr Kollege audresch
ein Christdemokraten des christliche
Menschenbild abzusprechen
und das noch zu verbinden mit einem
Vokabular wir sein regelsführer
ich finde das einfach eine bescheidene
Debattenkultur
und mein lieber Kollege Frank zierske
wir schätzen uns und ich sag mal
das war auch kein glorreicher Anfang
weiß Gott nicht da geh mal bitte in dich
Herr Minister Herr Heil sie haben
begonnen ihre Rede mit der Zeitenwende
sie haben hier auf von Auswirkungen
gesprochen und die Frage Sie Herr
bündeln Bundesminister für Arbeit und
Soziales wo bleiben eigentlich die
Konsequenzen der Zeitenwende in ihrem
Verantwortungsbereich
und da sehe ich doch nur altbekannte
Reflexe immer wenn es Probleme gibt da
werden die mit Geld verdeckt und da
sagen wir als Union ganz klar das ist
nicht unsere Zeiten wenn wir wenn sie
sagen eine Lizenz zur Aufblähung des
Sozialstaat wir sagen und das zu
Unterschied wir lösen Probleme gezielt
anstatt durch immer höhere
Sozialausgaben diese zu verdecken es
müssen diejenigen gezielt unterstützt
werden die tatsächlich Unterstützung
benötigen
und da will ich auf ein Thema eingehen
und da hat die FDP heute gut vorgelegt
mit Frau raffelhüchen das ist die
Rentenreform
oder wollen wir
Generationengerechtigkeit herstellen und
auch gleichzeitig eine angemessene
Altersversorgung aus sicherstellen und
da haben die Rentner profitiert von den
Erhöhung und das wird auch bis 2026 gut
weitergehen und ich erinnere hier an die
16 Jahre wo wir die rettenkasse
fortlaufend gut angefüllt haben und ich
sage hier auch noch mal in aller
Deutlichkeit mit Blick auf zu neuen und
zwei zehn beginnen mit der Kurzarbeit
die wir auch in den letzten Jahren gut
angesetzt haben dass hier viele
Arbeitsplätze gesichert werden konnten
und das ist auch der rettenversicherung
zu Gute gekommen ich sage
unser Rentensystem ist noch Leistungs
und deswegen brauchen wir zügig eine
Debatte wie die Rente in Zukunft
aussehen soll aktuell kommen auf einem
Rentner zwei Arbeitnehmer wir wissen
dass in 2050 dieses Verhältnis auf eins
zu eins sich angreifen und deswegen ist
der Vorschlag der FDP zu aktienrente das
ein richtiger Gedanke aber wir sagen das
Volumen ist zu klein sie wissen ja wir
geben jährlich 340 Milliarden Euro aus
an die Rentenbezieher und wenn sie da 10
Milliarden nach dem dritten Haushalt
jetzt einstellen ist das schlichtweg zu
wenig
auch der Vorschlag von der SPD das
Rentenniveau dauerhaft festlegen dass
keine Lösung das ist wie wir sagen du
Vogel Strauß Politik ein verdecken von
Wirklichkeiten und vor allem ein
wecktuten vor Verantwortung es ist doch
gerade eine Belastung für die jüngeren
Generation die das schlichtweg nicht
schultern können und ich sage deswegen
wir müssen alle drei Pfeiler der
Altersvorsorge weiterentwickeln und da
müssen neue Ideen auf dem Tisch wie die
gesamte Bevölkerung bei dieser wichtigen
Frage ordentlich mitgenommen wird denn
wir arbeitet er wird Leistungsansprüche
und erhält dadurch weniger oder gar
keine Transferleistung und wir sagen
immer wieder arbeiten muss sich lohnen
und Rente ist nun für Lebensleistung und
das sollte auch gerade der Grundstock
sein für die kommende Reform des
Rentensystems
wir haben in die vergangenen Jahren auch
gerade bei Geringverdienern die
Betriebsrente gestärkt und ich muss
sagen für jeden Arbeitnehmer sollte es
zukünftig eine Betriebsrente geben und
wir brauchen ein neues Finanzprodukt für
die Altersvorsorge das gerade für
Beschäftigten für kleinen Einkommen auch
attraktives und das meine ich das sind
nachhaltige Konzepte die den Menschen in
unserem Land aus Sicherheit geben und da
fehlen die zukunftsorientierten Ideen er
heilen sie haben das selbst gesagt dass
gerade die Arbeit doch das Wichtigste
ist dass viele Menschen Arbeit haben
sollten und deswegen korrigieren wir
beim Bürgergeld und das haben wir
gemacht das hat auch die Einigung
gezeigt dass die Vermittlung in den
Arbeitsmarkt im Zentrum der Reform steht
und wir können das Sehen beim Bürgergeld
und auch bei der Energiepreis pauschale
die wir ja für die Rentner auch für die
Studenten immer wieder gefordert haben
und auch erreicht haben in den letzten
Wochen es kommt bessere Ergebnisse
zustande wenn die Union mit wirkt und
ich sage ganz laut und deutlich wir sind
das Kollektiv der Mitte deshalb fordere
ich Sie auf eröffnen Sie die Diskussion
Herr Minister um die Rente
ja und das war es und zu Rente schnell
der Nachtrag
112,39 Milliarden Euro fließen in die
Rente von den
166,23 Milliarden die der Einzelplan elf
umfasst hierzu liegt ein Änderungsantrag
der Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4.547 vor bestimmt zuerst über diesen
Änderungsantrag ab wer stimmt für diesen
Änderungsantrag
ich nehme an das ist die
cdu/csu-fraktion
und die Fraktion DIE LINKE wer stimmt
dagegen in der Tat ist das ein
Änderungsantrag der CDU CSU und sie
verlangen mehr Geld für die
Servicestellen jugendagenturen
dann kommen wir jetzt zur Abstimmung
über den Einzelplan 11 in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt
F das sind die Fraktionen der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP wer stimmt
dagegen das ist die Fraktion Die Linke
cdu/csu und afd-fraktion Enthaltungen
sehe ich nicht der Einzelplan 11 ist
damit angenommen
ich rufe nun auf den Einzelplan 15
Bundesministerium für Gesundheit
mit den Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksachen
3.514 und 3.500
sichtlich zufrieden mit dem morgigen Tag
wird das leidige Thema Hartz IV erledigt
sein man kann darüber diskutieren ob das
Bürgergeld die Fortsetzung ist oder eine
substanzielle Veränderung darstellt
jedenfalls wird es morgen den Bundestag
passieren können und dann den Bundesrat
und am ersten
wird dann das Bürgergeld in Kraft treten